this is jocko podcast number 325 with
echo charles and me jocko willink good
evening echo good evening and also
joining us again tonight is jason
gardner good evening jason good evening
[Music]
chicago times special
camp robinson nebraska may 24th
1877.
your correspondent has obtained some
very valuable information in regard to
the custer massacre
from crazy horse
through horned horse as his spokesman
which is authentic and confirmed by
other principal chiefs
i interviewed the chiefs this afternoon
lieutenant clark arranging for the
meeting and william hunter acting as
interpreter a man perfectly reliable and
thoroughly con conversant in the indian
language this is the indian version and
the first published the attack was made
on the village by a strong force at 11
o'clock in the morning at the upper end
of the village
this was the force commanded by major
reno and very shortly afterward the
lower end of the village was attacked by
another strong force
that commanded by custer
the village was divided into seven
different bands of indians each
commanded by a separate chief and
extended in nearly a straight line
the village consisted of 18
1800 lodges and at least 400 wiki-ups a
lodge made of small poles and willows
for temporary shelter each of the
wiki-ups contained four young bucks and
the estimate made by crazy horses that
each lodge had from three to four
warriors
estimating at three made a fighting
force
of 7 000 indians
this is the lowest estimate that can be
made for there were a good many indians
without shelter hangers on who fought
when called upon and the usual number
was much above seven thousand
the attack was a surprise
and totally unlooked for
when custer made the charge the women
papooses children and in fact all that
were not fighters made a stampede in a
northerly direction
custer seeing so numerous a body mistook
them for the main body of indians
retreating and abandoning their villages
and immediately gave pursuit
the warriors in the village seeing this
divided their forces into two parts one
intercepting custer between their
non-combatants and him and the other
getting his in his rear
outnumbering him as they did
they had him at their mercy
and the dreadful massacre ensued
horned horse says the smoke and dust
were so great
that foe could not be distinguished from
friend the horses were wild with fright
and uncontrollable the indians were
knocking each other from their steeds
and it is an absolute fact that several
young bucks and their excitement and
fury killed each other several dead
indians being found killed by arrows
horned horse represented this hell of
fire and smoke and death by intertwining
his fingers and saying just like this
indians and white men
these chiefs say they suffered a loss of
58 killed and over 60 wounded
from their way of expressing it i should
judge that about 60 percent of their
wounded died
while this butchery was going on
reno was fighting in the upper part of
the village but did not get in so far as
to get surrounded and managed to escape
they say
had he got in as far he would have
suffered the same fate as custer but he
retreated to the bluffs
and was held there until indians
fighting custer comprising over half the
village could join the northern persian
portion in besieging him
these indians claim that but for the
timely arrival of general terry
they would have certainly got reno
they would have surrounded and stormed
him
out or would have besieged and
eventually captured him
from what i know of crazy horse i should
say
that he no doubt is capable of
conducting a siege
in both the rosebud fight and the custer
massacre
the indians claim that crazy horse rode
unarmed in the thickest of the fight
invoking the blessing of the great
spirit on himself that if he was right
he might be victorious
and if wrong
that he might be killed
so
that right there is a excerpt from a
book called i fought with custer which
we covered on this podcast
podcast number 48.
you might want to go check that one out
and that's from a section that
we actually didn't cover on the podcast
the section of the book that's called
they fought against custer and it's got
a bunch of first-hand accounts from the
indians that fought against custer
and i didn't cover that section because
we had already covered the
native american perspective in podcast
where we discussed the book called
wooden leg
who was a northern cheyenne indian who
fought against custer
at little bighorn
and that's a
a good podcast to listen to i've got
quite a few seal friends that that's one
of their favorite podcasts
but this man that gets mentioned here
this warrior
he's mentioned in both those books
and
he's mentioned pretty quickly in both
the books but
he's
someone that is definitely worth
exploring
as a warrior as a man and as a leader
and jason you sent me a great book a
while back
called the journey of crazy horse this
book is written by a guy named joseph m
marshall iii
who
himself is a member of the lakota tribe
he was raised on the rosebud indian
reservation in south dakota
and he
he kind of
reports on or explores his journey of
discovering
and understanding
crazy horse
and starts off with the
with
a certain
a certain image of crazy horse and then
learns more about him over time
kind of going from a legend
uh you know held aloft
sort of above being human to being a
warrior to being a leader and then
ultimately understanding him as a man
and much of what he's you know i always
like to do the first person accounting
that's what i'm always trying to get
uh for the podcast
and this much of what
what joseph um talks about joseph
marshall talks about is stuff that was
passed to him through his elders
through oral history and that's i think
what what allows this book to come to
life
so well so
i guess we dive in
dive into the journey of the journey of
crazy horse
by joseph m marshall
iii
where did you find this book originally
so
i got a buddy that lives in uh iowa
chris anderson
and he sent me this book to read he's
like hey you need to check this out so
about two years ago
i knocked it out on audible and then as
we started to do the uh um you know
we're doing the battlefield at little
bighorn
i'm like well i want to understand more
about the
the for everything that koster did wrong
there's stuff that sitting bull and
crazy horse were doing right and i want
to try to understand more of that so i
hit this book up and then it made sense
for something that we could talk about
here yeah especially because it's from
the lakota perspective and and brought
down from their oral history yeah the uh
we're so the battlefield that you're
talking about this is an event that we
do at echelon front where we go and look
at the we go and walk the battlefield
and there's all these leaders to learn
from
i mean
we do gettysburg
and this will be the first one that the
first series that we're going to do up
at up at little bighorn
so going out there understanding the
personalities of these individuals gives
you so much more depth into
understanding their leadership decisions
and the decisions that they made you can
start to
identify how their personalities
impacted their decisions and then you
can look at yourself and say what part
of my personality is impacting my
decision
and
we i haven't been to have you been a
little bighorn yet yeah
i have
same kind of spiritual
impact as gettysburg yes and it's
incredible because you can you you can
sit you can sit in the gully where reno
had hit
they well they came across came across
the river and attacked the south end of
the the camp because initially they
could only see a portion of it and
thought it was much smaller and then
they the
morons didn't listen to their crow
scouts who said whoa that's a much
bigger encampment than you think it is
and you you can see all these spots
and
and it's just it's it's
it's really humbling to be able to see
it and talk about it and discuss what's
going on and and feel the energy that
was there
yeah i'm looking forward to when are we
doing that august it's august yeah
all right so let's get into this book um
here we go crazy horse has been my hero
since i was a boy
he was arguably the best known lakota
leader
in the latter half of the 19th century a
turbulent time on the northern plains at
first i knew crazy horse only as a
fighting man
the warrior
i didn't know or care what he felt what
he thought i cared only that he was a
lakota and that he was brave and
performed deeds that fired my
imagination
but as time went on there were more
stories
i now know crazy horse as a man
first and a legend second a very distant
second in fact he is much like my father
and my uncles and my all my grandfathers
he walks straight
he is polite
and he speaks softly
but there is also an aura of mystery
about him as though sometimes i am
seeing him in a mist that blends legend
and reality it's that aura that seems to
appeal to most people and i'm convinced
that many want to connect
with the mystery more than they want to
identify with the man i can remember
consciously
hearing his name for the first time the
summer i was six years old my
grandfather albert and a man i knew as
grandpa isaac and i had just crossed the
little white river and stopped to rest
as they both fashioned their roll your
own cigarettes one of them compared the
slow
the slow
moving little white
to the greasy grass river
i learned later that the greasy grass
was in south central montana and was
also known
as a little bighorn
in the shade of a thick grove of sandbar
willow the two old men spoke about a
battle
and names that i had never heard before
or at least that i couldn't remember
hearing before rolled off their tongues
that day along the river
one name
was repeated more often than the others
in the story of that battle
the name his crazy horse he was a leader
of fighting men and his mere appearance
on the battlefield was apparently enough
to inspire others to fight
crazy horse had led a charge of warriors
against the soldiers in the second
engagement of that battle
a leader commented on that particular
action
when recounting the battle years later
by saying i have never seen anything so
brave
by the age of six i'd already listened
to many stories from these two
grandfathers i was well aware that being
a fighting man was one way of being a
man in the lakota ways of old
i knew that men were often injured or
wounded in battle and sometimes killed
and i knew that in a battle a man could
prove himself
for one man to obviously evoke such
reverence and respect from two
grandfathers who told the story of 1876
greasy grass fight the battle of little
bighorn
was
of some consequence
in my six-year-old world i could think
of only two or three other old men in
the same category as these two
grandfathers so when they respected
someone it was no small thing
that day by the little white river crazy
horse became a part of my life
um
we were having this conversation i think
yesterday
this idea and i i think i had brought it
up on some other podcast but
the idea that
this
if you're gonna go out and fight
is that programmed into us
is that just what we're raised with that
we think hey going out and fighting and
being heroic being a warrior is a cool
thing is a good thing
or is there some sort of
genetic component to it because as a
human being
in a group of other human beings that
are trying to survive
10 000 years ago and we're part of a
gang we're part of a tribe and if jason
is the kind of guy that goes out and
you know kills a buffalo or defends our
tribe then you help us all survive and
so we're naturally we naturally
intuitively instinctively elevate the
people that are ready to fight and we
can't even control it i don't know what
do you think
yeah it's it's interesting because the
good hunters also translate to their
good warriors right but then in in their
society in the lakota society the
medicine men were also
revered as well
so
i guess people were elevated based on
whatever they brought to the community
with large and then
oftentimes with either the medicine men
or the warriors eventually you age out
of it
and then then they're looking at you for
for your wisdom yeah
you know uh so like chamberlain
that guy comes over from like the
intellectual side of the house because
he's a college professor when he joins
the army so it's kind of like he wasn't
really that's what makes him so
interesting and so cool is he's like
good at everything every side of the
rubik's cube you examine with that guy
he's squared away solid colors yeah
the thing is though you have all these
different societies around the world
that are some of them are totally
disconnected from other societies and
there's like always a warrior tradition
yes it leads me to believe that at least
at some level
human beings
look at the person that's ready to stand
up and fight and defend and they have an
instinctual inherent elevation
elevated attitude towards that person
here this guy's six years old you know
i'm thinking and he's hearing these
stories and thinks it's cool
in the parlance of our time right like
hey that's wow this sounds cool what was
i doing when i was
eight years old watching apocalypse now
thinking that's cool
that guy he's special forces he's going
on this mission up the river that's cool
i i don't know
i mean my dad wasn't in the military
there was
no my grandfather was but he wasn't
super influential in my life and all of
a sudden as just instinct
that looks cool
it
yeah because it doesn't appear to be
generational even in this case crazy
horse's dad is a medicine man he's not a
fighter yeah um
and so
you know i
you look at how we
revere
sports figures in in a lot of ways
they're warriors you choose the sporting
team and they're the ones that are going
out and doing battle with other sporting
teams or rooting for them and there's
who we're putting up on a pedestal
for the most part
it's not that different than
than combat which
isn't going that on it's an interesting
thing to discuss it feels like there's
an element of risk there too like so
skill and then risk and sacrifice for
everybody sacrifice for everybody else
and their their lies in why we hold up
like that courage
as being a value that we
or something that we value right is
courage
yeah like if you if you're let's say i'm
a six-year-old or whatever and you think
of some guy who goes out and kills a
buffalo and then brings it back or
whatever right
you think man if i want to try to kill a
buffalo that thing's going to kill me
you know so he's like good at what he
does he's risk dying and then when he
brings it back it's for all of us he's
like hero you know right so kind of it's
i mean that's obviously like a metaphor
or the the sporting teams and stuff
that's a metaphor yeah yeah that's a big
one that's the same thing though yeah
exactly but i and i think this is is so
obvious what we're saying i guess my
actual
question is
is it
instinctual
is it like part of our nature
that we you know it may or may not get
you know uh expanded upon as we grow up
and some people you know
being a warrior is stupid why would you
go out and sacrifice yourself for other
people like that's an attitude so you
can overcome this instinct
but
it is kind of crazy
to to think hey this is the way many
different societies from all different
background all kind of elevate this
warrior
is it an in is it a natural
animal instinct
to think this person is going to protect
the tribe this person is going to help
the tribe this person is going to feed
the tribe this person's possibly going
to sacrifice for themselves for the
tribe and that's a positive thing and
we're going to elevate them because
they're
putting the tribe before themselves
they're putting themselves at risk in
order to save the tribe and that's why
it's very likely instinctual
and
i i don't
i don't i think that's no matter where
you look if you examine closely that's
still revered today
um this individual human overcame the
the
instinct of self-preservation to look
out for me
and look out for my family we're going
to elevate that individual
all right
going back to the book here
every lakota baby was born with thick
shiny black hair that stayed black for
most of adulthood
but the hair of the son of crazy horse
seemed to grow lighter even as he lost
his baby fat which happened to him
quicker than in most children
to his mother and the other women in his
life it was an endearing characteristic
although they worried that it would
prove to be troublesome for him later in
life
outside the reach of sharp ears he was
referred to as the light-haired one
to his face he was simply called gigi
or light hair
so he's got a distinctive characteristic
out of the gate
which is
also kind of interesting you know you
gotta
uh my name is jocko which is a weird
name and i've had that it's a nickname
but it's been my nickname since i was
born which meant when i met someone when
i was five years old
and seven years old and four years old
and 10 years old
they would say what's your name
and i had to say this weird name you
know my name is jocko like that's a i
didn't really know that that was just a
nickname until i was a little older
so you kind of have to contend with this
right it's kind of like oh you got to
contend with this what having a weird
name you have a weird name yes i know
that do you know that yes sir i do
did you did you feel that a little bit
like when you were six years old yes
i did you did yeah now jason was like
hey i'm jason good you have to spell it
you don't have to mispronounce it you're
just good to go yeah no
so i think these kind of distinctive
characteristics can sometimes help
they can also sometimes
i think
hurt kids
uh when you're young you got some weird
like sometimes happens kids grow really
tall quickly yeah and they don't they
don't like it you know they feel like
awkward or people are looking at them or
when you get glasses right that's
another thing maybe it's not that big of
a deal when i was a kid like when
someone had glasses yeah they had to
contend with that yeah you had to deal
with it but they're tempering them it's
making i mean that's the metaphor he
uses in here that the teasing tempers
crazy horse to make him hard and it's a
boy named sue yes that's exactly what i
was thinking about and his metaphor is
like hanging the staff in the tp for
five years to slowly temper it and make
it harder and then you're gonna carve
that ash dive into a bow um
we were talking about buds earlier
and
amazed that there's still a huge
attrition rate and and our thoughts are
it's because a lot of the
some of the folks that are there are
such good athletes they've never failed
at anything whereas opposed
when i got there and and i'd already
failed at a bunch of stuff and i was
used to getting beat up and getting
knocked down it's like okay i'm just
gonna dust myself up and get moving
again yeah you and i were saying that
when they when the instructors looked at
us and said you suck we were like yeah i
know obviously but but if you're like
the star athlete and you get told you
suck
and you and then you lose the race
because by the way because you're so
athletic they make you do a bunch of
jump squats before you do the sprint
race and then you lose
and then they call you a loser and it's
never happening before and all of a
sudden you're like i i this isn't for me
i can't win in this arena or i'm not
good enough
and meanwhile you got joe slightly below
average athlete which is me
just like well i'll keep going i suck
yeah i know but i'm going to keep going
i'm used to this yeah
the other thing and
he mentions in the book i'm not gonna
highlight it but the they called him the
women decided to call him light hair to
just get it over with it was like hey
you know oh
you got you look a little bit funky cool
we're just gonna we're just gonna bring
make it we're gonna call you that just
get it out in the open
get the elephant yeah in the room out
why not yeah isn't that what all the
psychology does it's like oh you're
afraid of elevators so let's make you
look at a bunch of pitchers elevators
and eventually maybe you get in one and
then late you just do graduated exposure
and that's what they did here appears to
work yeah it's okay to be offended
everybody and make it harder
uh there came a day when someone handed
light hair a bow and a quiver of arrows
to suit it to his size and strength it
was the first tangible sign of life that
lay ahead and his mother smiled because
she was proud her son would follow the
path of a hunter and warrior hey
the caveat obviously not reading the
whole book it's an awesome book
if you if it sounds a little stilted
when i'm reading it like wait what's
going on because i'm not reading the
whole book
get it
and and the audiobook you mentioned i
think the audiobook is read by the
author so that makes it cool too
change came into light hare's life this
is fast forward change came into light
here's life in yet another way she who
gave him life lost her own
in the perception of the child at the
time
the perception of perception of time for
a child can often be irrelevant
especially in a culture that was not
given to measuring it he was too young
to understand that death is a part of
life later he would realize his mother's
time on earth had been much too short so
his mother dies when he's young
um fast forward a little bit more
seasons turned
and i just just fyi
you know being a guy that's into
language and stuff there's a whole
section that this thing starts off
talking about the the language the
lakota language really cool to read i'm
not gonna read it for two reasons the
primary reason being just me sitting
here trying to pronounce these words
would be a disaster
but they add a lot to the story when you
when you read the story so another
reason to get the book
one
one day light hair and his sister were
given new mothers they were sisters
quiet and polite as they walked into the
circle of their new life as the wives of
crazy horse so the crazy horse that
we're talking about in this particular
moment is the dad
the dad that you mentioned jason is a
medicine man so the dad is named crazy
horse at this time and that's where
they're talking about when they refer to
crazy horse not light hair the sun who
is the crazy horse that we all know
about
and they're mothers and daughters of his
own son
um going forward a little bit more the
boy didn't completely understand all
about his father but he did know that
crazy horse didn't hunt like the other
men or go to war a father who was a
medicine man and didn't do the things
men did
caused the boy to feel all the more
different
he wondered most of all why he looked
different than the other boys so that's
another
thing in his childhood everyone's
talking about my dad's and the teams or
my dad's going to war and he's like well
my dad's going to go uh you know move
smoke around and stuff
so he feels awkward about that
hunting was the lakota lifeblood
like the wolf fox eagle mountain lion
and hawk the lakota were hunters at age
seven light hare realized more and more
that hunting was the way to have fresh
meat and deer and elk hides for clothing
and buffalo hide for lodge coverings he
also sensed that he would be part of the
process somehow like all boys light hair
was becoming skilled with his bow
he had progressed to a stout a stouter
bow stronger than the first he was given
one made in proportion to his size and
strength his favorite game had changed
as well shooting arrows through a
rolling willow hoop had become too easy
and boring
so his uncle little hawk and a few other
men introduced him to a new game
shooting at grasshoppers
the rules were simple
walk along the prairie with an arrow on
the bowstring and shooted a grasshopper
when it flew a rolling ho a rolling hoop
was a much easier target a grasshopper
was about the size of his little finger
and flew erratically and fast the men
would suppress smiles when at first the
boy was unable to get off a shot
before he could pull back the string the
insect was back in the grass
but as he learned to hold his bow ready
he could send an arrow in the general
direction of the flitting grasshopper
shooting at grasshoppers was not boring
it was he learned a very humbling
experience
as the summer wore on his reaction
became faster and more and more his
arrows only narrowly missed
grasshoppers an old man told him have
much to teach
uh awesome
just awesome stuff you're going out to
see dudley aren't you i am and you're
getting i was just thinking that i
wonder if
that or is going to start doing that
walking around
zapping grass oh yeah you're going to
get dialed in um
freaking awesome
what a
what a way to grow up and what a way to
get good
you're just that's what you do
it's what you do
fast forward a little bit important
character comes into play as the days
passed he unknowingly attracted the
interest of a and curiosity of a man
called high backbone
the mini khan jew with the ogallala wife
oglala wife
and he liked what he saw in the shy
light hair
and i might i might i don't think i've
mentioned that yet so
marshall mentioned it um that
crazy horse is quiet and he doesn't talk
a lot but they they do give some
examples in the book of when he's a kid
they're playing games and he's not
saying anything you know he just he's a
quiet he's a quiet
the term he used here is shy perhaps it
was the boy's quiet determination or his
innate humility
high backbone himself was a quiet man
not given to pursuing the path of glory
but he was deeply committed to achieving
the status of wika
the complete man
the complete man embodied the best
qualities of the hunter and the fighting
man
though all men necessarily filled the
roles of both provider and protector the
hunter warrior not everyone could
achieve the highest ideals for both
callings
high backbone was one of the few
high backbone was a leader of fighting
men muscular and broad shouldered
exuding the confidence of a man who not
only had physical strength but also a
lifetime of experience and
accomplishment
so this guy high backbone kind of
becomes a mentor
to
to light hair and
this idea this idea of being good in
multiple phases you know so what who are
you saying about the rubik's cube
chamberlain chamberlain yeah because
it's like you know yeah he's good on
every side that you examine yeah and
that's
that's what high backbone has that same
quality
um they lay out these these virtues of
the weka which i thought was was really
interesting um go
and it's it's in the forward but it says
the the virtues are generosity courage
fortitude and wisdom
those and the very first thing they're
saying for a warrior and a man is is
generosity
which is
pretty cool courage and fortitude and
wisdom
yeah
um
fast forward a little bit
like most lakota boys approaching the
age of 12 light hair was a proficient
hunter like all hunters light hair
learned to sit motionless in the
driftwood blind along a creek for the
better part of an afternoon waiting for
a white whitetail to move with an
effective killing range of his bow which
is as far as he could throw a stone with
all his might
it's pretty cool that's a pretty good
uh
i'm thinking he's probably able to go
60 yards what's your estimation i don't
think oh no he's 12 years old throwing a
rock he's 12 years old he's throwing a
rock
what do you think he could throw a rock
i think he's probably at 15 or 20 yards
really yeah
echo charles assessment 35 40. though
think about it what's his drop what's
his
strength yeah 12 it's it's probably not
that'd be pretty small yeah yeah that's
a good point
but dude we're talking about a kid
that's just walking around freaking
shooting grasshoppers all day long so
and if you heard about like the um the
the the old british
longbow archers that had like a draw
weight of 120 pounds or something and
they weren't compound bows they were
just drawing back that much weight yeah
so
the mongols had 80 pound bows i think
that's insane that's insane yeah um
would be interesting to hear what their
their what they some someone will know
or put in the comments yeah someone will
tell us somebody'll tell us what the uh
what that range was
so he's hunting um
here's another he's got another friend
[Music]
another friend named lone bear fast
forward a little bit lone bear and light
hair rode straight to a slight rise
north of the fort and this is so now
there's they're doing exploring kind of
like kid stuff
and they go to look at fort laramie
warned by crazy horse that's the dad and
high backbone not to go nearer
but it was a good enough vantage point
to see buildings in the surrounding area
a wide trail led to the fort from the
southeast and away to the west
on the other side of the main area of
activity which was among the
light-colored buildings and along the
trail
what were what they could only assume to
be abandoned wagons
they resembled skeletons most of them
stripped down to the frames whites were
everywhere
along with their horses mules oxen and
cattle the occasional barking of dogs
reached the boy's ears
south of the buildings they could see
the tops of several lakota lodges
a few lakota stayed near the fort from
the days before the soldiers had taken
over in the days when it was only a
trading town
now the rumors were the soldiers had
come to protect the travelers along the
shell river trail
and again
um
there's he gives a lot of good detail
about all the way this settlement is
happening the whites are coming how
they're doing it what it looks like to
to the indians
um
i
yeah and i'm trying to give enough that
you can understand the story
there's a real bad smallpox outbreak
prior to this happening a lot of them
are just like
just i'm staying away from white people
period yep wiped out entire
groups of people yeah um
yeah they're scared of that they don't
want any of that
the lakota called it the council at
horse creek
the white peace talkers called it the
fort laramie treaty council of 1851.
the whites wanted three things
first they wanted no more fighting among
the people gathered
the black fleet the black feet and the
crow were called upon to live in peace
with the lakota and the lakota were in
turn to live in peace with the snakes
and so on
tell the wind to stop blowing some
reacted or the rivers to stop flowing
second the whites
seem to want to say where the land ended
and where it began by drawing a picture
on a parched hide
beyond a certain line was crow land and
behind it was black feet
but who could find that line on the
earth
someone wondered
third the travelers on the shell river
trail must not be molested they said for
they were traveling under the protection
of the great father who lived in some
city far to the east of the grandfather
river
the great father would know if his
people on the trail were harmed
the trail must be holy in some fashion
suggested an old lakota man riley
thereafter the shell river trail became
known as the holy road
for agreeing to these three things the
peace talker said
the great father
was empowering them to pay annuities
that amounted to many thousands of their
money in dollars the annuities would be
in the form of food
beef cattle flour and beans for starters
and various other goods such as plows
hoes and other farm implements
there were many raised eyebrows and
helpless shrugs at the listening of
listing of other goods but in the end
they were accepted
very
very strange you know like it's just a
complete
it's a culture
just
totally separate
even as you're hearing this deal
you're thinking wait you're going to say
this land is my that's like if you came
into me right now and said hey a jock
i'll give you money for your for the air
i'd say uh you want to give me money for
air cool
okay you give me money i then all of a
sudden you had some contraption that
like sucked the airway yeah exactly i
was trying to wrap my head around this
whole thing and you're that's exactly
what's what's
what's going on and it's it's clear that
like
the whites there they
they obviously weren't organized and
sound kind of screwed up to because they
had their stuff they were trying to
muddle their way home things through
this this this whole mess on
like hey yeah we've got annuities coming
and then they don't show up and they're
like
what's up the annuities too is a real
good
you can see and we're gonna see it
throughout this story
just the way that
we as people if you become reliant on
someone else if you're giving stuff and
you become reliant and you forget how to
do things for yourself
you know i don't know if the grand plan
of the whites was to get them hooked on
these annuities and then we can just
kind of take advantage of i don't know
if that was their grand plan but that's
what happens
it definitely like it part part of a
three-prong strategy won
the annuities which i bet you they were
just doing to kind of like calm things
down but then it wound up being like
what actually screwed everybody over and
it's so
relevant to today
right because these annuities are like
the algorithms on social media or
they're like
fast food or all kinds of other real
easy stuff
that's like oh cool i'll i'll just swing
through mcdonald's because i'm kind of
hungry and not order something healthy
off their menu
and
then then you're messed up yeah
yeah i mean anytime this is you know
from a greater perspective communism
right hey look i'm gonna pay you
regardless if you do your job well or
not
well okay cool i'm not gonna do my job
well and you're gonna pay me
right that's great it happens with you
know certain positions certain
government positions like oh you're
gonna get that you're gonna get that
paycheck regardless if you're at the dmv
no offense dmv but if you work at the
dmv it doesn't matter if you process
four licensed applications today
or 29
what's your motivation to produce any
more stuff if it's all going to get
taken from you and redistributed then
you're just going to do the minimum
and i think that's what the one of the
reasons why communism has kind of fallen
on its face and a lot of it is it's very
disturbing
so
fast forward a little bit each summer's
lines and lines of wagons were not the
same as those that had come the summer
before they carried a different group of
whites who had never seen a lakota or a
kiowa or a blue cow cloud
but who had been filled with stories
about the dangers from the brown skinned
marauders
so wide-eyed and fearful of were the
whites who arrived at the fort
not comforted by the sights of scowling
lakota men
but the lakota were likewise troubled at
the sight of so many white men
some of the old ones would shake their
gray heads and speak a warning
in any land among any kind of people
three human weaknesses are at the root
of trouble fear
anger
and arrogance oh my goodness say that
again
right how relevant is that to us today
yep
fear anger and arrogance those
weaknesses
were about to be mixed
yeah
fear anger and arrogance by the way
root cause of those obviously arrogance
is ego but anger often also ego
and
a lot of these circumstances
are very egotistical in this book that
that the anger is triggered from ego
yeah and the the
hatred which i think kind of is a little
bit different but you can attach it to
anger and usually it's rooted in some
kind of fear
life has a way of creating strange
circumstances that often lead to a bad
end
or an unexpected turn
when i read that i was like damn it
you know because you don't want to admit
that
you don't want to admit it you don't
want to say you know what let sometimes
things happen that result to a bad end
it's such a
sad thing to think about but it's the
freaking reality of life
so he goes on to this um
section here
that
speaking of anger and fear and arrogance
there's a there's a cow
that wanders into this camp and it says
it was into conquering bears camp that
an old foot sore cow wandered on an
especially hot afternoon
the lakota didn't own any cattle of
course so it was correctly assumed that
she had been lost or abandoned by some
white man
trying to escape the barking dogs she
was running between lodges knocking over
meat racks after the loft or stop
someone realized that although old and
thin she was fresh meat
so
they
you know they kill the cow
word of the predicament spread quickly
through the camps
because now someone's mad
if they believe it was a mormon they
called they keep calling the mormon man
the mormon
man
wanted the cow
he's complaining the soldiers that his
cow had been stolen
so word of the predicament quickly
spread through the camps the next
afternoon the soldiers started from the
fort in two wagons and with two wagon
guns
but the man leading them was not fleming
this is one of the soldiers that they
had worked with or knew it was one
called gratton
a new officer lately come from the east
with him was a man married to a lakota
woman a speaks white brought along to
translate gratin it was later learned
had been loud about his disdain for the
lakota so you got now an arrogant guy
that's also afraid
and when the soldiers reached his camp
conquering bear left his lodge to meet
them even as they jumped from the wagons
and formed two lions facing the camp the
old man was still trying to stop the
trouble
but his efforts were ignored meanwhile
the speaks white rode up and down the
line of soldiers shouting threats in
lakota
south of the camp hidden in low
shrubbery
light hair and lone bear so you got
young crazy horse and his little buddy
watched the old man and strained to hear
him but couldn't
gratton stepped down from his horse and
helped load one of the wagon guns aimed
into the camp
the officer shouted
the wagon gun blasted and all movement
seemed to come to a stop but for a
heartbeat
the tops of a lodge lodge's poles
splintered into many pieces then the
soldiers aimed their rifles and fired
before the echo from the wagon gun had
faded
astonished and unable to immediately
perceive the reality unfolding before
their eyes the two boys watched
conquering bear fall back struck in the
chest and stomach the second wagon gun
boomed and then the lakota men reacted
before the soldiers could reload their
rifles to fire again a few little coda
guns boomed arrows flew and then angry
men ran toward the scattering soldiers
gratton was one of the first to fall
so like that's how things kind of start
to go bad in the world it's like a
little misunderstanding then you have
that anger that fear that arrogance
and
initially they tried at some point prior
to this whole thing breaking out he's
like hey we're going to give you sorry
about the cow we're going to give you a
couple of good horses way better than a
cow in our estimation
in in trade for that and they're like oh
no no
that's not going to work
show up and start shooting which
obviously does not not work work doesn't
work out well for crap it doesn't work
out well for granted does it work out
for well for anybody no
there's a there's certain sections in
this book um
so there's books there's part of the
book he's telling the story of crazy
horse and he's got sections marshall's
got sections in here called um
called reflections
and he's got this one section
where he's he kind of gives his
perspective
on what he
on the events that he's kind of written
about he says and i'm not going to read
the whole thing there's a whole bunch of
incredible points that he makes he says
crazy horse came into the world at least
four generations ahead of mine he was
born in the early 1840s perhaps as late
as 1845 i was born in 1945 as lakota
males he and i have much in common
enough of lakota culture has survived
through changes during those four
generations fortunately to allow my
generation to identify strongly with his
so he has like things in common he says
this by the time light hair was 10 or 11
euro americans were a consistent
presence and an increasing annoyance the
oregon trail had been cut across the
southern part of the territory beginning
in the late 1840s it became a steady
stream of white emigrants moving east to
west from late spring to mid-summer tens
of thousands of people thousands of oxen
mules and horses and hundreds of wagons
passed through every summer for 20 years
those people carried with them many
things new to the lakota
some beneficial such as iron knives and
cooking pots and some destructive such
as liquor and disease most of all they
brought change
my grandparents and their generation
were not too different from light hairs
parents and grandparents the elderly
lakota of the 1850s in the face of the
white incursion and changes brought to
them were telling stories and reminding
their children and grandchildren to
remember that remember the trails they
had walked
handcrafting a bow out of ash is almost
allow lost art for the lakota
my grandfather taught me because his
father white tail feather and second
father
which is his stepfather henry tuhawk
taught him to make bows and arrows they
learned it from their fathers and
grandfathers
and the methods and process are the same
as those that were taught to light hair
exactly the same
each time i've had the opportunity to
make a bow
a thought invariably passes through my
mind this is the way it has been done
for hundreds of generations
i make my bows the same way crazy horse
did
that is only one of the many connections
i have with him as lakota boys
there's a great discussion somewhere in
this book where they're talking about
the elders and they're talking
specifically about change
and they're like hey
we used to use lance's to hunt the
buffalo before we came up with bows and
arrows and we transitioned over that so
we've got to be ready
to change
as things as things come along and they
give that historical example and that's
a struggle isn't it when when we think
of valued traditions that we have in our
culture
like what what do we strive to hold on
to and and and what do we let go of as
we grow yeah and there's i i don't
remember if i'm gonna cover this or not
but i'll bring it up right now one of
those same types of discussions
they're talking about there's a time
when it's time to get on a new horse
and like the old horse isn't working
anymore you got to get on a new horse
and and that's a good expression to keep
in your mind because you're riding that
horse and it's starting to fade or it's
not able to do its job anymore you got
to get on a new horse even though you're
comfortable with your old horse even
though you that old horse has been good
to you
it's not gonna work out anymore you
gotta be ready to transition to the new
horse
um
getting now back into the
the story
out of the reflections and back into the
story light hair had been in the camp
but a few days when a raiding party
prepared to go against the pawnee and
omaha
who had become too daring of late coming
north well past the running water he
accepted the invitation to go along
the raiders in the e the raiders went
east toward the loop river
an area of rolling hills and tall grass
and many deer there they separated into
two groups one turned south to probe
into pawnee country and the other with
spotted tail and iron shell leading had
spotted an omaha camp in the breaks of
the east in the breaks east of the loop
a small number of the group crept cloak
crept close to the camp while the rest
hid and waited
light hair was one staying close to his
uncle they crawled in among the horse
herd and slowly cut the hobbles from the
horse's legs and chased them out of the
camp though the omaha didn't immediately
respond
a large contingent soon started out to
recover their horses spotted tails group
waited a little longer then attacked the
camp
the few omaha men left in camp fought
hard but so did the lakota
spotted tail charged several times on
horseback alone and light hair claimed
his first victory as a fighting man
and omaha tried to attack through some
tall grass but light hair stopped him
with a well-placed arrow
the confusion and chaos delayed his
reaction to what he had just done though
he was vaguely aware of the man's death
throws
seized by a sudden bravado he crawled
through the grass to take the scalp of
his first kill
a wave of sickness swept through him
the dead omaha was a young woman
he turned away
the fighting was over
the raid had been successful though the
omaha had recovered some of their horses
spotted tales daring and courage was the
talk around the fire
light hair sat quietly wrestling with
the reality of taking a human life
like all newcomers
to it he had learned something about the
unfettered violence of combat
ordinary perception did not exist and
senses became confused the omaha who
attacked him seemed to move so swiftly
too swiftly for a deliberate reaction
on the other hand when he had let go of
her head because he didn't want her
scalp
everything around him see seemed to move
very very slowly
her hair was soft thick and very long
light hair said nothing although he knew
the overall outcome of the raid had been
good
they had no they had new horses and no
one had been hurt but the face of the
dead girl stayed in his mind
it's a humbling experience for him it's
just absolutely awful
you know
and
he
they go into it and we'll get to some of
these parts but you know when they get
done with a battle they go back and kind
of tell stories
and that's the norm
and he's already a quiet kid
and this just solidifies the fact that
he's he's not gonna talk about what he's
doing
a man from the fort came looking for
iron shell with a message from the
french
trader bordeaux
the long knives and it's a the long
knife is what they call the the soldiers
because they have long swords so they
call them long knives they call the
soldiers long knives
the long knives had received word that
the great father
which is basically when they say that
they're talking about the president or
at least some
form of the supreme government of
america the great father was very angry
over the killing of gratton and his
soldiers more soldiers were being sent
and their purpose was to punish those
who had done the killing
it was an ominous message but not one
totally unexpected
had the great father been told that the
soldier gratton had opened fire first
had the great father been told that more
than adequate payment had been offered
several times for the worst worthless
cow of the mormon white man
why should the great father care about
such facts someone asked
that was the problem
everyone agreed
the whites had one truth and the lakota
another
yeah
i haven't talked about that quite a bit
especially on the academy
um
i haven't used those terms you know i
have one truth and you have another but
i always say i have one perspective and
you have another perspective
and if you think that your perspective
is the right one you're
you're not correct i mean it's literally
not if you can't say that
you can't look at something you can't
look at a situation you can't look at a
plan you can't look at an idea
you can't look at a scenario
and say oh i see everything and i
understand it
the the old saying there's two sides to
every story actually there's 48 sides to
a story yeah right
there's all these different sides
and
when these things break down
it's because you're not listening to
other sides of the story it's not you
you're believing your own story your own
side of the story and you can't let that
happen and you have to you have to put
into your calculus that other people see
things differently if you don't put that
in your calculus you're not going to get
the right answer
so many of these wars
so many wars are just
misunderstanding start with just a
straight up misunderstanding or a little
incident that could be de-escalated it
just turns into a freaking disaster
summer passed light hair grew taller his
voice deepened and he walked with a
surer step
when there was dancing he stayed in the
shadows satisfied only to watch
light hair fast forward a little bit
light light hair remounted and put his
horse into a gallop from another and
higher vantage point he could see that
smoke was rising from the encampment so
he's out on like a little personal
patrol of his own which is he that's
another thing i haven't done a good job
indicating
he likes to be by himself
so he goes out and hunts by himself he
goes out in the woods and just sits by
himself he likes he's kind of a loner
so he's out on one of these sort of solo
operations
and he says
from another and higher vantage point he
could see that smoke was rising from the
encampment
a few her horses were scattered about
watching to the north but there was
nothing else no children playing no dogs
running about
leaving his horse hobbled he ran toward
the camp light was fading a dog barked
tentatively and a stench hung in the air
among the smoking lodges and collapsed
poles were objects scattered over the
ground
whatever had happened was over
an eerie silence hung over the camp
nothing was moving
the horses he had spotted earlier had
not moved they were still gazing
intently at something toward the north
light hair entered the camp the objects
seen from a distance now took distinct
shapes
they were rawhide meat containers willow
chairs clothing containers robes and
cradle boards scattered indiscriminately
as if by a sudden angry wind
but it hadn't been a wind
someone had attacked the encampment
the horses had been telling him
something looking north as they had he
walked over to a hobbled mare
she appeared unharmed so he fashioned a
jaw rope untied the hobbles swung onto
her back and urged her into a lope
toward the north where there had been
movement earlier
if the people in the camp were running
away they would be moving as fast as
possible
in a bare patch of ground he saw the
grooves left by a pair of drag poles
pausing to look he saw other signs of
drag poles
then he saw something else
even in the fading light the distinctive
prince of the metal shoes worn by long
knife horses
unless soldiers had taken to pulling
dragging poles something wasn't right
throwing caution aside light hair
galloped in the direction of the signs
and at the second or third hill he saw
them
people were walking and leading a few
horses pulling loaded drag poles though
it was difficult to count how many they
were
but on either side was a column of
mounted soldiers
they were heading northwest
most of the men from little thunder's
camp
had been away hunting
some of them were bound to return sooner
or later
but for the time being light hair was
alone
he returned for his own horse so he
could take two along to follow his
relatives who were captives of the long
knives
back at the burned out camp he retrieved
his gelding
and gathered stones from several cooking
fires and built a marker pointing it to
the northwest
anyone would know to go in that
direction especially given the condition
of the camp
he had only been in the south end of the
camp so he led his horse through it to
the north end
the mayor snorted in apprehension and
shied away from a long dark object on
the ground
light hair bent to it and felt a leg
it was a woman
she was dead
he discerned other shapes in the growing
darkness and went to them
they were all dead
he wretched after he bent low over a
woman and realized that both her breasts
had been cut off
searching in the growing darkness he
found one dead body after another all of
them scalped or mutilated in some
fashion
he wretched again and sat for some time
before he pulled a robe back from the
next body
a child this time perhaps ten
gathering his horses he walked out of
the camp
he had covered every body he found
covering the shame of the insults they
had suffered after the pain of death
with the shock and the grief came
another feeling
starting like a small cloud growing over
the horizon
anger
so
that's going to leave a mark
you get to a point where there's a
trajectory where it's it's almost
impossible to stop the direction that
things are going and when stuff happens
like that
what are you going to do
i i mean you you
through this book
you you have a problem because there's
this clash of cultures
and
the lakota have a culture that that
they're involved with raiding they're
going up and rating the crow they're
they're raiding the uh um
the snakes the snakes and the crow are
rating them back
and it's just
what they kind of do and there's an
equilibrium there because they're not
industrial and they can't like mechanize
death the way
the europeans are capable
at the time yeah and they don't
understand it
and there's like a
he doesn't say this at all
but you can assemble it there's an roe
like a legit rules of engagement
that they're following and you don't you
know there's just things that you don't
do
and there's times where he mentions in
the book
they're going to they're going on a raid
to like to stay sharp
yeah like hey hey look this is like a
training op yeah but it's real
and they're going to go do it and and
the other
the other tribes kind of know that's hey
this is part of what we do oh this is oh
they're gonna run a training op we're
gonna have to get some
but there's rules of engagement and
there's there's like
um hey we're gonna go in we got some
horses from you cool we're not
slaughtering your people we got we we
needed horses so we got some horses
right that's what we're doing oh we want
we wanna you know some of the meat that
you that you hunted okay cool we didn't
get enough so we're gonna go take some
of yours it's a it's like there's rules
of engagement that they're all operating
on they were i think it was fairly
common too when you raid like
they mention in here and he leaves out
like
we attacked the village and there were
no men left in the village or very few
of them what what did you do exactly and
i don't think it was uncommon for them
to snatch slaves up at a minimum
from other villages
uh i think you know the
empire the summer moon which is another
great book the comanche were grabbing
people from everywhere and then they
would just assimilate them kind of in
the tribe but they also
did a lot of slave trading and other
things
at the time so um
there's no one that's completely clean
in this whole situation
and
i
yeah it's just it's it's an interesting
study
yeah
on on all this stuff and and how do you
stop it
once once that boulder's rolling
downhill and like you he comes in and he
finds all these mutilated women like how
do you put that fire out now it's gonna
be rough
um there's a guy named harney i think
he's a carl maybe a general
general general harney
early in the morning the soldiers had
been seen moving up blue water spotted
tail and iron shell and a few warrior
leaders rode out under a white banner to
talk of truce to talk
the leader of the soldiers was a
white-haired man and bearded older man
who said his name was general harney and
they eventually put two and two together
that this is the guy that led this raid
word did come harney had stopped at fort
laramie since he was the leader of the
soldiers he declared an end to trading
with a lakota still demanding the
surrender of the killers of gratton
when the story of the attack on little
thunder's camp on the on the blue water
was carried north to the other lakota
camps general harney was given a new
name to the lakota he would always be
known as woman killer
so the fact that they're giving him that
specific name probably is an indicator
that it's not common practice for them
to kill women no that's what i'm saying
there's roes man that were violated big
time
one evening he returned from a long
outing with high backbone and waited for
his father in the lard lodge when crazy
horse that's the dad returned the boy
held out a bundle of tobacco it was a
gift an offering to a holy man when one
needed to speak from one's heart
light hair needed to tell of a dream a
dream that had come to him the second
night he had spent alone on a sandstone
bluff
it had been with him every day and night
for these many months he told his father
dreams were important crazy horse said
as he as he took the offering of tobacco
from his oldest son
so now we get into this dream
the dream was not difficult to remember
and this dream is like the central theme
of this book so the dream was not
difficult to remember only to tell
it had been a part of the boy since the
late summer night near the sandhill
country when old conquering beer bear
lay dying in camp after the incident
with the soldiers with the soldier
gratton and his men
he was almost embarrassed to describe it
the dream began at a lake a small still
lake
bursting upward from the blue calmness
a horse and its rider broke through the
surface and rode out across the land
the rider was a man a slender man who
wore his hair loose
a stone was tied behind his left ear a
reddish brown stone a lightning mark was
painted across one side of his face on
his bare chest were blue hailstones
behind him behind them to the west as
they galloped was a dark rolling cloud
rising higher and higher
from it came the deep rumble of thunder
and flashes of lightning
the horse was strong and swift and
changed its colors red yellow black
white and blue
bullets and arrows suddenly filled the
air flying at the horse and rider but
they all passed without touching them
close above them flew a red tailed hawk
sending out its shrill cry
people
his own kind
suddenly rose up all around and grabbed
the writer
pulling him down from behind
the dream ended
there seemed to be a warning in the
dream the glorious warrior in the dream
was grown but still young the faces of
the enemies that had sent bullets and
arrows at him were not visible but the
people who had pulled him down were like
the rider himself
they were easily seen as was the horse
the hawk and the thunders
the thunders they were the powerful
beings that lived in the west perhaps
the most powerful of all beings ever
anywhere
rarely did anyone dream of the thunders
and anyone who did had a special calling
to be a sacred clown the one who did the
opposite of what was expected light
herod described the lightning mark on
the dream
rider's face as well as blue hailstones
painted across across his chest
lightning and hail were both strongly
associated with the thunders
crazy horse
the door
crazy horse closed the door and began
singing again
and another gathering song to call in
the spirits he poured water on the
stones sending steam and new waves of
heat rolling inside the tiny
enclosure light hair endured the heat
even as he had held the dream in his
mind's eye as his father had instructed
him to do
dying gloriously making the ultimate
sacrifice in defense of the people was
the secret dream of every lakota
fighting man
it was the warrior code repeated in all
the honoring songs
the dream seemed to suggest that the
dreamer would gain honor and immortality
by living and dying as a warrior
but perhaps there was more to the dream
perhaps there was a warning of a path
that could not be avoided
so there's a lot of foreshadowing in
that dream
um of his life that he's not going to
live very long
he's not going to live to old age and
the scariest thing i guess is the fact
that people his own kind are the people
that kind of drag him down
from behind
um
and you know this this
got me to thinking you know when i had
when i had uh micah fink on the podcast
and
i started off by reading some stuff that
he's either said or written
and there was that one quote
this native american quote and i i don't
know which tribe it came from
uh
and i didn't research it but the quote
is
a diagnosis
becomes a curse basically you get when
you diagnose someone with something it
can become a curse
a self-fulfilling prophecy
you know and
that's um
to look out for
you know it's something to look out for
yeah it's it's uh um
i think it's better
as we go through the story to just
discuss it later the struggle that the
tribe has between
the folks that are
going to the take the free annuities
and the folks that are deciding to live
wild
and then that friction
and that friction
corrodes them from the inside out
yeah
like man the egos that come into play
are just very disturbing
mention he's a few more characters
coming to play even in the company of he
dog and lone bear light hair laughed and
smiled less often and didn't participate
in their banter as much as he usually
did this is after he kind of reports his
dream to his dad
his friends knew that crazy horse had
taken light hair off somewhere for
several days and that since returning
their light-haired friend was less
communicative
but they also knew that he always tried
harder to win
the games the boys played to emulate
warriors in fact he rarely lost
he was not always the fastest or the
quickest or the best shot but he simply
kept trying
and though he didn't tell them what to
do
they still followed him
because he didn't hesitate to take the
lead
he seemed to know instinctively the best
trail to follow or the best way to do
something
word of light hare's dream
had quietly spread among the fighting
men sooner or later some said the boy
would have to put his medicine to the
test
there was only one way to see if the
enemy's bullets and arrows would not
strike him
so preparations were made for a raid
north into crow lands crazy horse and
little hawk had found a reddish brown
stone for light hair to wear behind his
left ear and taught him how to paint
lightning and hailstone marks from his
dream
then a bullet gone astray while someone
was practicing
grazed light hair's knee
like a friendly fire scenario someone's
out just training and get and crazy and
light hair gets shot
though crazy horse his dad treated the
wound carefully to him it was a sign a
worrisome sign directly related to the
people in the dream pulling the writer
down
for the dreamer there would be danger or
harm from his own kind
um we get into
the love story part of this scenario
it's also
tragic in many ways news was buzzing
about a prominent family planning a
coming out ceremony for a favored
daughter there would be much feasting
and dancing red cloud was an impressive
figure of a man and had a reputation as
an orator
he was the head of a large family and
some would say he would be an important
man for years to come so it was only
natural that the people were excited
that his niece black buffalo woman was
to be honored
as a tiny doe eyed girl she'd crossed
light hair's path now and then now she
was a beautiful willowy girl with long
glistening black hair
light hair hung back as the crowd moved
away and managed to catch a glimpse of
her dress in a finely beaded dress
her hair in two long braids hanging down
over her breast signifying she was now a
woman that evening light hair stayed in
the back of the crowd during the dancing
black buffalo woman's brothers her
father and her uncle stayed close to her
as a reminder that any would-be suitor
could count on having to prove his worth
in order to become part of that family
so
he's got little love interest
black buffalo woman
fast forward a little bit waiting for
his first test to battle light hair
watch for the signal from high backbone
a stone's throw to his right
he had stripped to his breech cloth and
moccasins his hair loose in the manner
of his dream and the lightning mark and
hailstones painted on his chest
at the back of his head he wore the tail
feathers from a red-tailed hawk pointing
down as when the hawk was about to
strike his prey
behind his left ear was the reddish
brown stone in his right hand he held
the bow two arrows against his palm and
a third clamped in his teeth
his quiver bristling with arrows was
tied to the front of his waist to be in
easy reach
a shout came from high backbone as he
urged this his mount into a gallop to
take him up the slope light hair and
others did the same strangely each rider
had only a vague awareness of the others
though they could hear
clearly dozens of hooves clathering on
the rock rocky slope
low angry sounded humming noises buzzed
past their ears
the experienced fighting men knew it was
the sound of passing balls from enemy
muzzle loaders the gunshots could be
heard less than a heartbeat later
a man with a gun stepped out from behind
a rock light hare's shot was pure
instinct and he didn't see if the arrow
had hit his target
his horse pitched forward the enemy who
stepped from behind the rock had managed
to shoot the animal in the chest light
hair rolled across the rocky slope his
horse was dead his bow was gone he
quickly sliced the drag rope from his
horse and ran down the slope first in
one direction then another
a loose horse came out of nowhere and he
managed to grab a handful of mane and
swing on
there was gunfire from below
and answering fire from the rocks at the
top of the hill
the horse was rushing up the slope in a
blind panic and took his new rider among
the rocks
you got any commentary on grabbing a
horse by the main and just nuts
like that is so cool that that and it's
it's not his horse it's just the guy's
so good he's grabbing any horse that
comes by by the mane yeah just hopping
on sling back up back into the fight
the pistol he snapped off a shot with
his pistol he snapped off a shot at a
man who doubled over from the impact of
the bullet gaining control of the horse
he raced down the slope stopping to
recover his bow his quiver was still
tied to his waist high backbone joined
him his horse winded together they
charged up the slope again in and among
the rocks this time light hare used his
bow and put an arrow through an enemy's
chest gunshots rang out from among the
rocks and up from the slope bullets
splattered against the boulders or
shattered on small rocks on the ground
unable to load another arrow light hare
used his pistol again and another of the
enemy went down light hair jumped from
his horse to grab the hair of the dead
enemy a quick swipe with his knife
separated a patch of scalp as he ran
toward a second body and grabbed another
handful of hair a sharp smashing blow to
his leg knocked him over
he went down in a heap but hardly got to
his feet shouts and gun fire continued
bouncing off the boulders all around
light hair went from boulder to boulder
as gunfire waned and then he hobbled
down the slope
the fight was over
every one of the enemies had been killed
the lakota rode among the rocks on the
hill to make certain
and then came down to gather around
light hair
most of them had seen him in the fight
the bullets and arrows had not touched
him except when he tried to take a
second scalp
his dream was true they decided
high backbone took the scalps from him
and cleaned the wound in his lower leg
someone rounded up light hare's new
horse and they all rode away from the
hill a few scalps
dangling from lances or belts
horses and guns were the prize
as well as the emergence of a new
warrior among them
that night around the fire the full
impact of the battle settled in like an
uninvited and unwelcome history
men had been killed
light-haired killed two men the second
and third human beings he had ever
killed the first was the omaha girl in
the country far to the east three years
past
ghosts
the old warriors say where the price of
fighting man paid to follow the path of
the warrior
somewhere behind the noble and espoused
traditions somewhere behind the
achievements and the glory
the ghosts waited
and they would always be there
their dying would forever be a part of
the path of the man who took their lives
whether the act was honorable or
justified or not
their faces
and often their dying moments
could not be forgotten unless the heart
of the warrior was made of stone and few
could boast of that
though many might have secretly wished
it to be so
somewhere people they didn't know
wives and daughters mothers and
granddaughters would mourn
they would wail and gash themselves
their hearts torn in anguish
the path of the warrior was indeed
strewn with broken hearts like so many
stones on a long and winding trail
the victory dances honored the warrior
and the victory story
stories reaffirmed the tradition of the
warrior
but very little if anything
could chase away the dark memories that
always lurked
the ghost would always dull the edge of
arrogance and bring a cold feeling at
the most unexpected moments
such was the price
of being a warrior
you know as you're reading that
and you think about
he gets dressed up for battle
you know he's they're doing their war
paint and it's part of a ritual that
they're going through
um before they go into that and i think
the ritual is probably really important
to the human psyche to help you
set aside some of the fear
and the other things and and maybe it
might even help you with those ghosts a
little bit
i remember
on one of the early podcasts somebody
asked if you had a ritual before you
went out on ops and
and i think there there there is one
that a lot of people practice and it was
like
i'm going to change out all my batteries
i'm going to get all the old battle maps
out of my gear and i'm going to put the
new battle map and the new comp plan
then i'm going to go check my my radio
and then we have this ritual that
develops it's like reinforcing that
we're all getting ready to go on the
battlefield because like one of the last
things we do before we get in the
vehicles are getting helicopters is we
get together and we do comm checks
we're saying to each other hey i want to
make sure that you know that i can talk
to you and then i know that you can talk
to me and when you need help i'll hear
you and i'll come right and and that
it's a different kind of ritual but it's
actually kind of the same where we
present ourselves for inspection
from each other like hey check my gear
out and all of us sometimes some
platoons run differently where they'll
have one guy check it out
but
every platoon has a system
where you present yourself and you do
all these this this ritual to get ready
to go into combat and then you present
yourself to your
your teammate
like hey check me out make sure i'm
squared away and um
and then i'll check you out
and then we in that we're kind of
reaffirming all of our bonds and getting
ready to go
into the belly of the beast
yeah it's probably worth noting as a
leader to
make that a little bit more ritualistic
right so what can you do to make it a
little bit more ritualistic
and i i
i did this my first deployment to iraq
where we would before we'd get in the
vehicles it was roll call like we would
stand like we'd all stand around the
board with the vehicles a magnet board
with vehicles on it and it was you know
gardner yep you know willing here you
know just going through
that roll call that yep we're all here
we all know what vehicles we're in this
is who's going out tonight
and
we d for some reason
in in ramadi we didn't do quite that
ritualistic roll call
we had come up with a
more decentralized system for yup
everyone's good to go you know uh
probably just the vehicles you know one
you know six up fives up fours up three
step two step one yep we're good to go
we don't need to have everyone standing
around
but
as you're talking through this that
little nice little ritual
was a good thing
and
it gives you a
you know and i've talked about this
before the fact that in america we don't
really have a ritualistic solid
ritualistic to way to deal with death
there's not a protocol to follow of what
you're supposed to do in it and it can i
think leave a lot of open ends and a lot
of loose strings
because other cultures
have hey this day we're going to do this
kind of celebration we're going to say
this prayer we're going to
go to this place we're going to do this
thing and then it's over it doesn't make
any sense does it because dying is as
natural as being born yeah and why don't
we
like it's just like this weird gap that
we have where we haven't set up this
a way for us to just cope with it yeah
and
and even you know we have some rituals
like in the seal teams like okay we're
gonna go to the funeral we're gonna
we're gonna put the trident you know
we're gonna pound our tridents into the
casket like those are awesome things but
it's almost like the ritual
needs to have completion where you say
hey once you put that trident in the
casket
and you bury that casket
you know now you've
you've let that part of of that warrior
go and now you can move forward whatever
the
saying should be or whatever the
the ritual
because you don't really know that you
know no one said like hey man once you
do that it's okay you've given you've
given that warrior the
the most respect you can give him you've
given him
the most meaningful thing to you which
is your trident you've given it to him
you're gonna bury him with your trident
you're gonna be with him forever
and now you go back to doing your job i
kind of feel that way
you know i felt some level of closure
when i've done that
but
if it was a little bit more
if it was a little bit more codified it
might be even more healthy for guys
so i think the idea of rituals
are so helpful in everyday life you know
if you've got some rituals to follow me
people have all kinds of little rituals
they follow in everyday life right i get
up i brush my teeth you know i do a
certain i put on like i wear the same
clothes all the time to work out you
know what i mean i have these little
rituals and i pretty much wear the same
clothes every day by the way but
you got these rituals like this is what
i'm gonna do and it makes
things easier and and it allows your
mind to sort of
follow a
of a path
that that is already known
and i think that's really healthy
and i think that would help people a lot
you know it it's what's what's so cool
what's so cool is getting these windows
and what's really cool about the story
of crazy horses it was written
by a lakota and then we get a window
into their culture
it's not that much different than ours
no good grief they're talking about that
their virtues are generosity and courage
i think we see that as a virtue too
right they come back from war and they
have ptsd by the way yes
and and what these guys
the things that these are holding up as
high standards are things that we hold
up as high standards as well
um
yeah it's worth if you're if you're if
you're in a leadership position the more
ritual you can establish without getting
crazy you know without getting crazy we
don't create rituals for no reason we
also want to create rituals that become
um
constrictive
but putting some rituals in place
is a positive thing definitely
speaking of rituals that night there was
a victory dance
high backbone and the others described
the battle and their parts in it four
enemy warriors had been killed and by
the way they were fight i didn't i
did a bad job they were fighting against
uh some snakes yeah it was snakes that
they were fighting against snake tribe
four enemy warriors had been killed guns
and horses had been captured everyone
waited for the son of crazy horse to
tell of his deeds since according to the
other men he had turned the flow of the
battle
but the boy hung back reluctant to talk
winning with humility
he goes to sleep um
fast forward a little bit the sun was
high when he finally roused himself the
pain in his leg had diminished somewhat
and he managed to doze off a little
he sipped tea from the horn cup someone
had left by the fire pit and finally
dressed he stepped out from the lodge
and was surprised to see a crowd
gathered in the camp circle at the edge
of
it stood his father wearing his best
medicine robe decorated with long
strands of horse hair
a trilling arose among the women
his mother stood behind his father
gentle smiles on their faces and
unmasked pride as well crazy horse
lifted his voice in a warrior's honoring
song joined by his wives and light
hair's sister
after the song came more shouts and war
hoops and trilling
crazy horse lifted his hand and walked
forward and faced the crowd i give my
first son a new name this day he said
raising his voice
i have heard the story of the brave
things he did i am proud his mothers are
proud all of his family and friends are
proud of our young man
so this day i give him a new name
i give him the name of his father and
his father's before him from this day
forward i call him crazy horse
from somewhere in the crowd a drum
pounded and another honoring song was
raised and the crowd surged forward high
backbone little hawk he dog and lone
bear were among the many who came
forward smiling
crazy horse
the name flowed like water over the
rocks
there's a little ritual activity that
was a cool scene freaking outstanding
welcome to the club man
and this is
equally awesome or at least getting
close
so the father passed on the name and
took for himself another
worm
a name of utmost humility
in time even that name would have
meaning for he would be known as worm
the father of crazy horse
it's a like epic you just hey just call
me worm that's where we're at
that's the humility level happening
around here
hey echo can i ask you about a movie yes
sir of course um good fellas yes sir
there's that scene where
the main character
goes to jail
and he's just locked up for a little
time but he doesn't say anything and
then when he gets let's let out
everybody's yeah yeah that feels great
oh yeah when he was a kid that's when
he's a kid yeah you popped your chair
though yeah yeah yeah yeah
good good scene
yeah there's something about that uh
this is another thing we don't do great
in america um
you're a man now type thing that
ceremony that thing
uh you're a woman now you can see they
did it for
for both uh black buffalo woman and you
know like okay this is it
you're you're responsible now
we don't do a great job of that
i went through something like that in
the catholic church where i did
confirmation and and and so different
cultures have got it but as we've kind
of morphed away from that it's something
that we've lost so how do we
how do we replace it and it it
and in a way it's got to be something
that you earn right it's so much better
if you're earning oh for sure for sure
it shouldn't just be like okay
time and rate you turned
you turned seven you're a man now
isn't it graduating high school is kind
of like that though yeah yeah true i
mean i guess in certain families right
but you graduate high school they give
you like a bunch of stuff
and then your uncle or whoever gives you
like advice it's like an actual thing
so i'm saying
dude
a podcast on the advice you got from
your uncle when you graduated high
school became a man bro that might be a
whole podcast series i'm just saying you
know you
well oh you didn't get advice from your
uncle no sir oh not me i'm just saying
you have a lot of extended family where
i'm growing up uh no no no not really
yeah and i didn't either but that's like
some people do and that's a great
benefit because then there's all these
adults putting good stuff into the kids
ears and like they you you read in this
book where there's everybody's talking
so everything's kind of common knowledge
and everybody's involved in developing
well one of the folks
in hawaii it's very common to call like
if you have a respected family friend or
friends that come around you call them
uncle or auntie 100 like i didn't even
know uncle was my mom and dad's brother
sister
i didn't know that until like a year
yeah yeah but it's it it feels more
solidified in hawaii because like i said
i was like 10 maybe 11 before i realized
oh wait like uncle is like if you're
actually related to him yeah you just
call it there's people now even that i
still call uncle jill uncle whatever
like you can't help it but um yeah so i
mean it's in a way it's kind of it's
kind of the same thing yeah when you go
great when you graduate they're all
there and they give you you know all
this stuff i got
i got put in check on that stuff by my
wife because when my son was like
six
and i was treating him like a team guy
and my wife's like he's freaking sick
idiot i was like
well still he should still be over
freaking you know
she just had to like crush me and i said
oh yeah sorry about that i mean you know
you have to be smart enough to listen i
had to think through it
i had to think through it and i was like
oh wait a second when i was seven
i realized i was like oh my god i'm an
idiot
because i was thinking you know why
would you not just do you know why would
you not get up at four in the morning
yeah yeah and i'm like bro
was i when i was seven i didn't even
have any concept of any of that you know
i was a little boy and they're always
looking at my kid like
you better get up
yeah
don't you want a jock steel
what you
this kettlebell is for you son
he can't respond because he can't talk
yet
you know uh little kids have blankets
yeah didn't you do your kids have a
blankie
uh
yeah my mom that's a big thing with my
mom because she got the kids their
special blankie and and but it it wasn't
like a security thing or not okay so one
of my kids i think my um
second daughter had like a blanket that
went with her everywhere my first
daughter not so much
i didn't know what was gonna happen with
my son so
so i got him like this uh
old school like sas freaking scarf thing
and i was like if he needs a blanket
it's gonna be freaking tactical
and you know what he rejected he never
had uh he never had like that that that
uh he never utilized it too early yeah
well no no he was my
one my daughter that had the blanket
that really carried it everywhere it was
what is it called knitted it was knitted
and it had kind of like big yeah shots
and had big knots so you could kind of
you would constantly be
uh fumbling with them right makes sense
yeah so but and the sas thing kind of
had some little things i said you know
that'll be you know help the dexterity
we're working on dexter at a young age
you want to be working your grip
strength so and my wife's like you are
such a freaking idiot
so there you go yeah but he was
definitely your son from straight away
because i remember him coming over
early on and i had like a hatchet laying
around and you're like
you can't have that hatchet he'd already
grabbed it you got it from him real
quick right before our pot belly pig
tried to eat him
my neighbor came out we we saw one of
our our old neighbors uh great friends
of family great people and they were
like yeah we were looking through
pictures the other day and he had a
picture of my kid at he had walked over
to their house and he's like
six
and he's got a naked barbie
a hammer and a nail and he says can
shane come and play and
darren goes yeah he can hold on a second
went and took a picture he's like this
is just too awesome
some freaking poor little barbie dolls
about to get crucified
uh
twisted times
okay
going back to the book there there's a
they're doing a raid
once again on the snakes do you know to
your point jason this is what they were
doing yeah it's not like all the
all the the indians were out there
kumbaya just you know
living in peace and harmony they were
killing each other
and that's what's going on here um they
got a raid they're on a raid on the
snakes it's going sideways
crazy horse found good cover but was
soon surrounded and his horse had been
captured incoming fire prevented him
from reloading his rifle without a
horse's odds of survival were great
greatly reduced his best chance was to
move out of harm's way but he knew he
had to act quickly the sound of distant
gunfire was growing fainter meaning the
herd of new lakota horses and most of
the raiders were now well to the north
he and a few of the other lakotas in the
trees were left on their own with more
snakes arriving
moving from tree to tree he waited for a
snake warrior to pass close and jump
behind him onto the horse dispatching
the man with one swing of his
stone-headed war club
any commentary on that besides us
how are you jumping onto the horse
that's just like athletic prowess as
well
pulling out his pistol he opened fire to
distract the snake circling outside the
trees and shouted for the lakota to make
their escape making the break from the
trees crazy horse and his companions
gained a good head start before the
snakes could regroup the snakes
continued to pursue the herd and at one
point managed to recover a few of their
horses but they had lost several more
men and soon disengaged
never in recent memory had the ogallala
lakota taken so many horses in one raid
but they had suffered losses as well
with at least five men killed
victory stories abounded and the dances
went far into the night the lakota
learned that one of the snake casualties
was the son of their head man
the young man had been one of the first
to pursue the lakota
once more young crazy horse did not
participate in the dancing in fact he
said nothing even to his father about
the new horse he was riding or the new
muzzle loaded loading rifle he had
brought back
worm could only guess how his son had
acquired them until one of crazy horse's
companions who had been in the trees
surrounded by snakes
told him what he had witnessed that the
young man had unhorsed a snake and
captured the gun in one daring moment
his action had saved them all the man
was certain
this is just a good
methodology for life
if you talk about how awesome you are
you're degrading your level of respect
as a human
so just don't do it it's just better
just to not say anything
how much more awesome is that is this
situation because crazy horse just rolls
back in with a brand new horse a brand
new rifle and doesn't even tell his dad
that he did this thing and he has to
hear it secondhand
12 years of one-on-one instruction
provided by
provided any lakota male
the basic physical skills to be a
fighting man by the age of 15 or 16 any
boy who is proficient with all of his
weapons but unseen factors determined
how each would-be warrior would handle
live combat
after the first few encounters with
enemies on the battlefield young crazy
horse had demonstrated qualities that
eluded many men for an entire lifetime
older experienced men while initially
impressed waited to pass judgment
however
it wasn't unusual for young men to
perform well in their first face-to-face
encounters with enemies if for no other
reason then that their inexperience made
them less cautious
then the daunting realities of combat
became part of their thinking and the
same young men who seemed so daring and
reckless and their first few outings
hesitated taking stock before taking
action
caution was good it turned reckless boys
into thinking men and a thinking man was
overall more valuable on the battlefield
than one who placed others in danger
because he took unnecessary risks
so the old man who heard so the old men
who heard of the first exploits of young
crazy horse nodded knowingly remembering
that such and such had started the same
way and now he was a man with a family
because there was little more to life
than glory on the battlefield
some wisdom from these
from these folks
they know what's up
the reckless die young the old men
advised and their only legacy is a brief
moment of glory but it's over time it's
forgotten it is the steady and the
steadfast that prevail the old ones say
so while it stirred the heart and the
imagination to hear of the exploits of a
new young warrior one whose quiet ways
in camp contradicted the stories of
daring on the battlefield the old men
puffed on their pipes as they sat around
the evening fires and nodded knowingly
over time young crazy horse would give
up his reckless ways they said
everyone does
not quite everyone
meanwhile the lines of suitors at the
lodge of black buffalo woman we're as
long as ever
she's
squared away
um and the town or the village is kind
of taking notice as time went by even
the staunchest skeptics agreed that
black buffalo woman and the stalwart
young crazy horse were a good match and
that she would do well to bring such a
man into her family
but there were still many whispers
behind the hand that her family had
plans that didn't take the girl's own
feelings into consideration
one of the suitors was no water
who of his own accord was by no was no
comparison to crazy horse
but no waters older brother black twin
was a skilled orator
and a man of growing influence and he
held many opinions solidly in line with
those of red cloud so no water was
suddenly a valuable man
there was nothing for anyone to do but
wait and watch with great interest
as to what would happen so you got
crazy horse he's sort of the
he's like the the warrior in this
scenario and then no water who has a
little bit of prestige some family
connections and there's a there's a
mystery as to what's gonna happen and
who's gonna end up
getting black buffalo woman
going out in the field again scouts from
one of the camps along the powder river
met the returning warriors and were
quickly sent back to spread the news of
success
but before he left
one of the scouts let slip a bit of news
from the red cloud camp that was like an
arrow into the heart of young crazy
horse no water the younger brother of
black twin
had become the husband of black buffalo
woman
out on deployment
and he was supposed to go on that
deployment and suddenly he got up two
things yeah he got a two-third they're
like oh go back to the camp and then you
can marry a black buffalo woman dirty
trick jody always there staying in camp
yeah
uh the grain of hope that light hare
dared to allow himself hold to hold in
his heart had grown into distinct
possibility when
as crazy horse he joined the line of
young of hopeful young men waiting
outside the girls lodge that grain of
hope had grown even more each time she
stood with him under his cording robe
and seemed reluctant reluctant to leave
his embrace or perhaps it was only his
imagination this would not be the first
time imagination
totally ignored his imagination totally
ignored the boundaries and limits of
reality
so he gets heartbroken
half a month later he returned fast
forward a little bit
uh
crazy horse said nothing of the trail he
had traveled for nearly a month for
nearly half a month
worm knew that the broken heart was not
completely healed and perhaps never
would be but he knew as all fathers do
that sometimes the best medicine for
such a wound was life itself
some good advice right there
yeah because he had left he'd gone out
kind of just on his own for a few weeks
to get
get over the the heartbreak
he does a little bit of raiding all on
his own too yeah which is something that
he gets into just
just solo operations
um
more good comments here a wound on the
outside can be watched to see that it
heals well as everyone knew
wounds on the inside could not be seen
but for pain in the eyes several months
had passed since black buffalo woman had
taken no water as her husband soon after
they had moved away
four as everyone knew no water was
afraid of crazy horse
the old women knew that best of all but
if their young man as they called crazy
horse bore any ill will it could not be
seen in the way he conducted himself or
heard in any words he had spoken
so they hoped that the wound inflicted
by black buffalo woman was healed
though some didn't blame her
she was after all only 16 and how could
one so young stand up to the powerful
ambitions of her father and uncle
um
rolling into the back in one of the
reflections sections here
and and again i'm
skipping a bunch of stuff
um
but wanted to talk about this part where
he says where marshall says the seeking
of a vision is a serious highly
ritualized process undertaken
respectfully prayerfully and under the
guidance of a medicine man to seek a
vision is to seek guidance for one's
life or to answer a problem or
predicament young light hair was
probably afraid that the dream he had
that night he spent atop a sandstone but
butte would not be taken seriously
because he had not followed all the
rules but it came nonetheless
the dream that vision has been told and
retold thousands of times since the fact
of the matter is that we cannot be
certain of the exact description of
light hair that light hair later gave to
his father furthermore it is critical to
understand that much of the discussion
and interpretation of the vision has
occurred and is still occurring since
crazy horse death
there are those who see the vision as a
foretelling almost a blow-by-blow
revelation of what lay ahead for light
hair it depicted a powerful lakota
warrior rising out of a lake during a
thunderstorm on a horse that changes
colors riding unscathed through a hail
of arrows and bullets until he's
eventually pulled down by his own kind
grabbing and holding back his arms
the vision might have been
as much a consequence of wishful
thinking as it is a glimpse into the
future for every lakota boy grew up with
dreams of being a warrior and winning
glory and honor on the battlefield light
hair was no different one elderly lakota
storyteller was of the opinion that
light hair and his father chose not to
tell everything about the vision
speculating
that a warning was part of it a warning
that the boy would die as a young man in
his prime
such a warning could explain crazy
horses daring and often reckless
exploits in combat as a younger fighting
man
perhaps he believed each time he was
about to perform the last act of his
life and wanted to be powerful and
meaningful
yeah man the guy's got a broken heart at
this point
and essentially like they're talking
about these other warriors get a family
and that now they got something to lose
and crazy horse
doesn't
it's like the classic but i don't want
to take that take that away from his
courage or bravery or anything else
either yeah the classic you know team
guy on the ragged edge with nothing to
lose right that's like
hey
ready to go
uh getting back into the story
crazy horse decided to see for himself
how things were at fort laramie
he found a loafer camp which is these
are like indian camps that are right
outside and they're friendly with the
whites and make deals with the whites
and they kind of live off the white they
call them loafers he found a loafer camp
a short way from the fort and stayed
with them a few days to hear what they
knew
annuities were late again they
complained and the longhorn cattle were
skinnier every year
they noticed not without some degree of
envy that while crazy horse carried a
rifle and a pistol and a far-seeing
glass
he was not dressed in white man's
clothes as they were
he reminded them he was a hunter
though some of them took this remark as
an insult others knew that living off
the promises of the annuities was not
really living
the white man named bordeaux
could speak lakota very well and he was
surprised to see someone from the
northern camps among the loafers he told
crazy horse that more soldiers were
coming to be posted at laramie
he knew this because the whites had a
way of talking over great distances that
was much faster than letters carried by
stagecoaches and the pony riders they
had a tapping language which by which
they sent messages along a wire faster
than even the prairie falcon could fly
um
now what starts happening is there's
there's they start to find gold look for
gold discover gold
and there's
people heading north of elk river to
find gold
north of the shell river
and these are
super intrusive right
um
and here we go after several days travel
north of shell river the people in the
gold seeking train woke
awoke to an unexpected site
they were surrounded by hundreds
of mounted lakota
and science fighting men positioned on
the hills and ridges around them the
trail north and south was blocked the
blockaders stayed out of rifle range and
didn't make any aggressive moves simply
maintaining their positions as the day
wore on a ring of men and horses seeming
to have risen out of the rocks after
nightfall a ring of small fires burned
morning light revealed the blockaders
were still in place
days and nights passed into five and
then six so these these
this big uh
train wagon train is up looking for gold
and
the
the indians
team up
they team up
and they surround them
super strategic what they're doing too
super strategic because they're not
they're not but they're not killing all
the women and children
which is going to commit everybody to
something they're just like
hey
and i'm sure those people must have been
horrified
uh
he says here there were only two ways
for the whites to go continue north
returned south if the soldiers came and
tried to take gold seekers north the
lakota and cyela would attack it was
decided if they turned back south they
would be allowed to return hopefully
with knowledge that powder river country
would not be another trail for the
whites whatever their purpose or
destination and then some soldiers come
and thankfully they turned they turned
the train south
and this is what i think is an important
piece
crazy horse would always remember the
strange episode on the snake staked
trail especially in light of all that
was to follow he carried a lesson from
it that he would use as a measure every
time he looked to the trail as a
fighting man
all the warriors on the ridges
surrounding the gold seekers had invoked
a feeling of virtue of simply coming
together a feeling of strength that
comes from pursuing the same purpose
several hundred had responded
some from the sahelia
and perhaps a few blue clouds married
into lakota families he knew several by
name but most were unknown to him
on those wind strip windswept ridges for
six days however they had shared the
kinship of purpose
so it incredibly imperson important
lesson for him unifying people and
working together towards a common goal
that's an opportunity
yeah and and so when people feel like
they're part of the group um
they're they're they're
they're capable of so much more and so
that means
that no matter what you do make sure
that everybody feels included on the
team it's that easy i have a simple uh
statement about this together we are
stronger
and if you can keep that in mind it's it
actually is like it's cover and move
because with cover move if you get too
far apart
now we can't cover and move for each
other together we are stronger if you
keep that in mind whenever things are
happening you think hey together we're
stronger that's the way you want to go
and that's the lesson he learned here
uh fast forward a little bit summer past
lazily and people talked about making
presents to the buffalo scouts and
sending them out looking so the
so the planning for the autumn hunts
could be made as the first heavy snows
fell troubling news came from far south
from the sahelia
who
lived along the southern fork of the
shell river soldiers it was always the
soldiers
300 people had been killed at a place
called sand creek most of them ciela and
some blue clouds led by black kettle and
white antelope
both leaders were regarded as wise and
always working for peace the killing was
bad enough because those killed were
mostly women and children but the
soldiers who attacked did more than kill
the white agent trusted by black kettle
and white antelope had advised them to
find a place to pitch their lodges that
was away from the main trails it was
told there were many whites in that part
of the country many living in a large
town called denver and there was a
hatred among them
for the sahila
and people of the earth
the camp was to fly the white banner of
peace as well as the striped banner of
the long knives to signify they were
peaceful
but the soldiers found them
and the banners meant nothing
the messengers could barely tell the
story trying to keep back the anger and
the tears as well as the bile that rose
in the throat for remembering women and
children were butchered after they were
killed it was told parts of their bodies
were cut away such as a woman's breasts
and genitalias
a child's hand or fingers and boy's
genitalius
brains were bashed out with gun stocks
and eyes were gouged out some babies not
yet born were cut from their mother's
stomachs
the final insult came when the soldiers
attached body parts to their blue coats
and rode in a victory march through the
streets of the large town as the other
whites cheered
the lakota did not want to believe the
news not because they wanted to deny the
truth of it but because it was much too
difficult to believe that anyone could
do such unspeakable deeds
sand creek massacre
um
i did a podcast about that with
danielle bolelli and daryl cooper we we
talked about the eli masker and the sand
creek massacre and it's just a freaking
nightmare
all the whites were not were the enemy
now
and that thought was carried with guns
lances war clubs and bows as angry men
rode out from the great camp the lakota
swept to the northeast the sahelia
to the northwest and the blue clouds
swirled like hornets in between
way stations soldered soldier posts and
tr any travelers along the holy road or
any frequented by whites were the
objectives young men took admonitions of
their elders to heart
as they hardened themselves to mercy and
remembered sand creek
the spirit of revenge rolled with the
thunder from hooves of war horses across
the frozen prairies
crazy horse joined the second attack on
julesburg but the whites were reluctant
to meet them face to face in the open so
there was no fighting to speak of
they left the post ablaze after taking
all they could carry from the
storehouses
so they they go and they're just out um
doing these raids and just
getting after it essentially right now
we're at total war we're a total war and
and yes we are and here's here's the
disturbing thing is
those
those uh soldiers at sand creek
they were
you know not connected to the soldiers
that were in
montana not connected to the soldiers of
these other forces they didn't know what
had happened and or maybe they knew what
happened but they i'm sure some of them
said what the hell is going on with that
just and so now you had you have
the
whites that are that have been looking
at all the indians as the same i mean i
guess maybe not because they they are
they are have some uh
like the crows they work with the crows
directly but you're starting to see the
two sides divide and it's you're either
on this side or that side and that's it
and we're going to take vengeance on if
you're white you're you're getting
attacked
yeah and rightly so
and now if you're a defender of the
people then that that's what you you
have to do and it just turns its
attrition warfare yep
and it's just uh it's not
it's just escalation and it's not going
to stop
so they're out doing these raids we're
going in these battles crazy horse
continues to distinguish himself
um
here's here so here's something that
occurs they had not succeeded in wiping
out the soldiers because a few
impetuous young men couldn't hold
themselves back for the right moment
this was on a an ambush
and some of the young guys went hard
early
and so it was a problem that had had to
be corrected if they were to defeat the
whites they all agreed and one way to
solve the problem was to find strong
young men to lead the others
for that they said perhaps they should
renew the tradition of the shirt wearers
some people scoffed at such talk no
shirt wearers had been selected for a
generation because the purpose behind
the tradition had been forgotten a shirt
wearer was to be a young man of strong
action and good ways one to set the
example for others instead the tradition
had become the father choosing his son
to wear the shirt next
better to let it be some said instead of
dishonoring a good thing
so they they used to have hey if you
were a badass you'd get this shirt but
then eventually became you know oh it's
my son i'm gonna get him hook him up
little hawk was growing into a daring
fighter already winning several war
honors but the most perplexing and heavy
change was symbolized in the shirt made
from the hide of a bighorn sheep now
rolled in a decorated case and waiting
his parent in his parents lodge also
waiting with the duties and
responsibilities that came with it the
old man leaders
had indeed decided to revive the old
trad the old tradition of shirtwares and
as expected the shirts were given to
young men of important families
so they do end up saying all right we're
going to make some shirtwares the choice
of young men the choice of young man
whose enemies are afraid of his horses
sword or long knife horse aka an
american horse surprised no one so
that's a bunch of guys that were
you know from from important families
but when the name of crazy horse was
announced
was announced a gasp went through the
crowd
and the shouts the whoops and the
trilling that followed were the loudest
of all
he felt truly honored yet was uncertain
that he was a good choice
later two more short wearers were chosen
and he was pleased that his friend he
dog was one
the other was big road a good strong and
honorable man
to wear shirts you must be men above all
others
said an old man chosen to speak
you must help others before you think of
yourselves
help the widows and those who have
little to wear and to eat and have no
one to help them or speak for them
do not look down on others or see those
who look down on you
and do not let anger guide
your mind or your heart be generous
be wise
and show fortitude so that the people
can follow what you do and then what you
say
above all have courage and be the first
to charge the enemy for it is better to
lie a warrior naked in death
than to be wrapped up well
with the heart of water inside
so that's uh uh an expanded version of
what you were talking about earlier when
they talked about the the
um
this idea of the short wars and again
what do they talk about
i i mean they open it up with think of
others before you think of yourselves
that's the that's the that's the opener
you know and essentially they're
choosing their officers right yeah
and it's pretty cool because
well i guess part of it they're doing it
by birth because they're like oh you're
from an important family kind of like we
did it yeah um
and then they're like
you know where it's like college degree
or land owners are going to be officers
and everybody else is enlisted and then
um
and then buy actual
prowess merit merit for crazy horse
you know and then then you serve others
before you serve yourself
and there's a tradition the marine corps
has
that's freaking awesome and that's what
the officer eats last
that is is similar in that
leaders eat last
that's as it should be
you know absolutely as it should be
fast forward a little bit calling the
young men together high backbone scolded
them for causing the ambush to fail this
is after they'd obviously just failed on
an ambush the young men listened without
protest as he reminded them that
fighting the whites was not a war for
glory but a war for survival
he reminded them of sand creek when he
finished there was a loud affirmation
but an even louder one came after he
announced his plan for another ambush
most of the fighting men would hide
themselves and their horses in the
ridges and gullies on either side of the
wagon trail from prairie dog creek to
lodge trail ridge a small group would
attack the wood gatherers who always
went out from the fort by wagon in the
morning when the soldiers came out to
drive the attackers away 10 decoys would
show themselves and lead them toward
lodge trail ridge
and then north down us down to a slope
ending in a meadow before prairie dog
creek when the signal was given the
hiding warriors would attack and not
before or
and not before or the ambush would be
spoiled the soldiers had to believe that
only 10
decoys were fighting them
most important to the plan were the
decoys if they failed several hundred
fighting men would be denied the
opportunity for victory therefore the
decoys needed a strong leader one
skilled in warfare with proven judgment
in battle the leader of the decoys would
be crazy horse
the cries and shouts of affirmation rang
through camp and fighting men young and
old crowded around to put their names in
as one of the other nine
they do some preparation then the attack
came came well away from the fort but
still within sight so the lakota could
be see surrounding the wax could be seen
surrounding the wagons so these are the
these are the uh decoys going into
action after initial charge the
attackers attackers kept the wagon men
and escort riders engaged the gunfire
sounded especially sharp in the frigid
mountain air soon the western gates
swung open and a column of mounted and
walking soldiers appeared the lakota
attackers kept up the firing making sure
the rescue column was well out of the
fort as the soldiers passed their
thicket crazy horse and his decoys
charged so this is like going as perfect
to plan as it could go
fortunately enough of the decoys
fortunately enough of the decoys had a
few bullets that they could fire several
shots to make it seem like an all-out
attack crazy horse shot a few arrows
when he was close enough to see the
hairy faces of some of the soldiers for
some moments the soldiers seemed
confused then they finally opened fire
uneven snow covered the
cover over the frozen ground and
dangerously frigid air were the decoys
decor warriors first obstacles and
bullets humming past them like angry
bees reminded them that they had a
daunting task ahead and a long way to
finish it the first few mounted soldiers
turned off the trail to pursue them and
the rest of the column fell in slowly
behind them
fainting head-on charges the decoys
would swerve at the last moment well
within range of the soldier guns they
took the soldier north the soldiers
north over the frozen snow fields at one
point some of the decoys including crazy
horse had to ride down a treacherously
steep frozen slope
the soldiers took the gentle slope of
the south face and kept pursuing an open
valley with thick stand of trees on
either side of the creek lay ahead with
no serious obstacles to impede the
soldiers advance once across the creek
the warriors turned straight north and
came inside of lodge trail ridge
the walking soldiers were slowing down
the column crazy horse dismounted well
within rifle range pulled out a knife
and calmly scraped the ice from the
bottom of his horse's hooves
when bullets began to ricochet closer
and closer he remounted and loped away
the other decoys to infuriate the
soldiers used similar tactics
fast forward a little bit on the ridge
i think i want to say i read that this
was about a
multi-mile like a five mile trail
they had to make a move five miles they
had to get pursued for five miles
on the ridge
the soldiers hesitated perhaps waiting
for some to catch up the decoys renewed
their efforts coaxing their tired horses
part way up the slope moving dangerously
close one pretended to be shot off his
horse and immediately bounced up running
behind the horse before skillfully
remounting from the back crazy horse had
picked the right men for the task at
hand
for crazy horse and the decoys this was
the decisive moment if the waiting
ambushers attacked prematurely soldiers
could still escape the decoys looked
left and right as they proceeded north
along a very narrow part of the ridge
but could see no movement
below the slope of the ridge falling
away before them was the winding prairie
dog creek and the end of their task now
the soldiers were pressing harder
increasing their gunfire obviously
certain that the decoys comprised the
entire enemy force crazy horse formed
his men into a skirmish line and those
with bullets had spit
with bullets to spare fired at the
oncoming soldiers drawing into heavy
drawing in heavy return fire
the decoys raced their horses down the
slippery slope forming two lines as they
rode they crossed the flats to prairie
dog creek each line of riders swinging
out wide and then crossing each other on
the opposite side of the creek
this was the signal to attack
from out of the very earth itself came
the awaiting ambushers
horses and men burst from the gullies
cutbacks and what little winter
shrubbery was there
in a heartbeat several hundred fighting
men rose rode south some from the east
and some from the west
those closest to lodge trail ridge
quickly shut the soldiers escape route
back to the fort
the soldiers advance stopped then they
instinctively began to fight their
to fight to reach the safety of the fort
the walking soldiers were strung out to
the back
closer to lodge trail ridge
they were the first to fall as gunfire
blasted up the slopes below them there
was no end to the guns firing the
soldiers fought hard as they retreated
up the ridge
but there was nothing to be gained
they were cut off with nowhere to go
wave after wave of the mounted warriors
fought their way up the treacherous
slopes those with guns used up their
bullets and then resorted to their bows
some had only bows and arrows arrows
flew up from the east slope and from the
west the sky was dark with them and some
found their mark in the body of a lakota
or
sahelia toward the end the warriors
waited in among the dead and dying
soldiers killing them with a pistol shot
or a hard skillful swing of a war club
or the deadly thrust of a lance
and then all was quiet
all the soldiers were dead
it began with the sahelia
as they remembered sand creek and what
had been done to their relatives when
the frenzy ended the soldiers were
stripped naked fingers were chopped off
bellies slashed open eyes gouged out
many warriors were wounded but fewer
than 15 had been killed
kind of a
kind of a perfect operation really i
mean it sounds just like a textbook
operation
and those soldiers got lured out i think
there ended up being 80 of them
um and they were all killed and then
mutilated
fast forward a little bit snows came and
winter past
a loafer brought word from the peace
talkers
they had come with more presents kettles
blankets knives and now guns and they
were asking for red cloud to come and
sign the papers that all the lakota
could share in these gifts so there
could be peace in the power powder river
river county the peace talkers had come
with a new offer as well all the country
from the great muddy river to the
shining mountains would be lakota land
so long as the rivers shall flow and the
grass grows
where the whites where did the whites
get the power to give the lakota lands
they already controlled crazy horse
heard many old men ask
crazyhurst's horse rode north to raid
the crows he returned with new horses
and to news that his uncle's spotted
tale had his own lands to live on given
him to him by the whites
agency it was called
crazy horse pondered this news even as
red cloud road south to fort laramie
with a new power of his own
he made a mark next to his name on the
white man's piece of paper and that was
the fort laramie treaty of 1868
it's
you know if you can get some people to
compromise and you can make some people
you can win some people over and you can
divide people
yeah right there there's there it's just
done yeah
um
there there's a funny discussion in
there where they're like how is
red cloud signing away our land yeah oh
he is well hey i'm gonna sign away my
brother-in-law's lodge yeah yeah
yeah
it doesn't make sense to them right
it doesn't it's just
again it's like hey
jason i'll give you money for your for
your air and you go well
okay what about oh do you want to buy
echoes there too i can sign for echoes
there
yeah i'll buy that too
or you know i look at equine say hey
already got your hair you know jason
sold it to me you're like what what just
happened
you know i i
but at the end of the day
those guys
whatever their motivations were
they kind of saw the writing on the wall
and they got on the winning side and so
they were trying to carve themselves out
even though
you know they're
maybe they're they're betrayers or they
are betraying the other lakota but um
it's that change thing again yeah it
likes it yeah
you sometimes got to change that horse
uh
returning from a hunt crazy horse
stopped in the camp of no water to rest
since the great gathering below elk
mountain two years past he had spoken to
black buffalo woman several times
whatever had been between them had long
passed she was the mother of three now
and seemed entirely proper for him to
ask about her children but each time
they talked
they lingered longer
something that did not go unnoticed by
someone who knew what had happened
before so now
black buffalo woman waited discreetly
for the gift of elk teeth crazy horse
had lately been leaving for her with
someone
but as he was preparing to leave she
approached openly and brought him food
and they stood together talking he left
not lingering too long but as he rode
away some noticed that she watched until
he was out of sight
worm
spoke and there was there's some
some talk about what was going to happen
with black buffalo woman there's
obviously a rekindling of this thing of
this relationship of this this uh
this love at first sight that they had
had
worm spoke nonetheless because much road
on the shoulders of his son much that
was important to the people they will
not let her go he said quality quietly
fast forward a little bit one morning
after victory dances whispers flew
through camp
black buffalo woman had left her
children with relatives and rode out
beside the light-haired one
no two people could agree over this new
turn some said it was a coming for a
long time since her father had made the
choice of a husband for her when her
heart belonged to the shy quiet young
man who is now the most powerful warrior
among them
others said there would be trouble
though she was a good lakota woman free
to choose her husband was not one to let
her have that choice besides the reasons
her father and uncle had influenced her
choice of a husband were even more
important now some said cautiously and
they were right
the couple and their friends came to a
small camp in a narrow little valley
and there they rested
little shield he dog's brother and
little big man were among were along and
made a feast as night fell there came a
commotion and a man tore into the lodge
where crazy horse and black buffalo
woman were guests
a man worn
from a hard trail and driven by anger of
a jealous heart
no water stood above them a pistol in
hand
as crazy horse leaped to his feet
the pistol boomed
so
got a little uh
love triangle going on no water is not
happy then
maybe i didn't cover it but
the tradition was if the woman wanted a
divorce she could do that it was up to
her
and and the man was supposed to respect
it but everyone kind of knew that no
water was not the kind of guy that was
going to let this slide it appears that
there's like there's there's a lot of
politics involved with this marriage and
it was an arranged marriage which is
kind of outside the norm too
um
what an incredibly tragic story
so
luckily enough back to the book he
awoken in a lodge unfamiliar to him but
knew the strong old face that appeared
as his eye cleared and he could see one
eye was still swollen along with the
left side of his face old spotted crow
his uncle the brother of long face
nodded a greeting and held him down as
he tried to sit up she is back with her
people the old man said and answered the
question on his face my cousin bad heart
bull made it so no one will harm her
he had been in and out of sleep for
three days he was told the swelling on
his face had gone down a little but he
would have a scar where the bullet had
opened his face from the corner of his
nose down to the jawline
there will be black powder in the scar
from the pistol worm had indicated
two very fine horses were tr were tied
outside his uncle's lodge sent by no
water as a gesture of peace
take them his father advised to soften
the anger of those who would take
revenge in your name
so he did
and the young men who wanted no water
turned over to them set aside their
anger and put away their bows and guns
then one night the young men who had
gone into snake country with little
hawks slipped back into camp sorry i'm
fast forwarding a little bit the raiding
so before we go there
he
he humbles himself basically he humbles
himself the guy comes to kill him shoots
him in the face
he happens to
live and
instead of starting a freaking war yeah
he says all right you know what i accept
the horses
there's just for some forgiveness and
acceptance and everybody can move on yep
um
so fast forward a little bit now
then one night the young men who had
gone into snake country with little
hawks slipped back into camp the raiding
against the snakes did not go well on
the way home
little hawk was killed by whites in an
unexpected attack the news was like a
war club to the stomach as his mothers
began to weep softly crazy horse went
out to stand alone in the night his
brother had been killed while he had
been chasing after his own selfish needs
so i don't probably failed to make that
clear but little hawk we've mentioned a
few times was his was crazy horse's
little brother and so while crazy horse
is going through this drama
and injury and recovery they go out on a
raid and his little brother
out with
i think is out with him out without his
older brother for the first time dies
the next day he saw no water unloading
meat at the lodge of a relative
seeming to sense crazy horse's anger no
water jumped on his horse and galloped
out a camp perhaps unable to contain his
anguish over both the loss of the only
woman he wanted and the death of his
brother crazy horse grabbed the nearest
horse and gave chase across broken land
he kept up the chase until no water
plunged his horse into the elk river and
escaped on the other side
not many days after that the council of
old men met influenced by the relatives
of red cloud and no water
crazy horse was to return the shirt they
decided his actions over the warm woman
endangered the peace of the oglala
and no one outside
like no one
like no outside enemy could
and this could not be overlooked
though there was anger in his own lodge
and from the young men at this trickery
crazy horse gave back the shirt
soon after that the lodge of no water
moved far south to another camp and
whispers were made
behind the
hand that red cloud was to be given the
shirt
this is
like you said there's just a trajectory
that
that gains gets gaining speed
you know you lose
you you either now you lose your woman
now you lose your brother now you learn
lose your
placement with the shirt as a shirt wear
and the friction points are you know him
in red cloud
and so what is he doing he's still
fighting
and who's he fighting
on
i guess unfortunately he's fighting
snakes he's fighting other other indian
tribes
going to this section here they attacked
but the snakes were too many the two
lakota groups were too far apart to
regroup and the mud was too deep their
horses tired somehow they managed to
hold back
the determined counter attack crazy
horse high backbone and good weasel with
their rifles were rear guard as others
retreated
first one fell back then another
managing to keep the snakes at bay but
several snakes on fresh horses suddenly
were able to surround high backbone
and crazy horse saw his old friend take
a bullet in the chest
still the old warrior pulled out his
pistol and emptied it at the onrushing
enemy until they overran him
crazy horse ran in to rescue him but his
horse was too tired from pulling himself
out of the mud
and the enemy fire was too much good
weasel finally intervened grabbing the
rain to his horse the rain turned into
snow as they rode toward home sometime
in the night they found a sheltered
place and built a warming fire with with
their horses while their horses rested
crazy horse sat huddled beneath his robe
alone with the thoughts of his old
friend and teacher
so i mean this is again it's just an
it's just a
downward spiral at this point
they get back to camp crazy horse smoked
his pipe and pondered all that had
happened since he and he-dog had carried
their lances against the crow
much had been taken away it seemed first
black buffalo woman then his place as a
shirt wearer now his younger brother and
his oldest friend were gone
he took little comfort in knowing they
had died on the path they they had
chosen
there was only emptiness where they had
been
perhaps these things had come to pass
because he had not fully honored the
calling to be a thunder dreamer
though he had learned the importance of
honoring the old ways from his father's
and from his father and uncles and his
mothers
he was not one for ceremonies or
standing in front of the people
but if he must live the life of
sacrifice he would as a thunder dreamer
he did not belong to himself he belonged
to the people
it was not what he wanted for his life
but it was what life wanted from him
as going forward a little bit this sort
of collaboration with the whites
continues and it continues to escalate
and finally at some point crazy horse
returned home to resurgent rumors that
miners were going into the black hills
in violation of the rules set down in
the horse creek treaty gold was the
reason ah yes gold the white man's god
the whites were willing to risk their
own lives to get gold
gold was the reason for their interest
in the black hills the heart of
everything
that was to the lakota
so they got the sacred the sacred black
hills and the whites
want to get gold
this is um
this is going breaking away from the
story for a second and going into the
one of the reflections sections from
from marshall in this point um
most boys therefore basically learned
the same lessons and were given the same
opportunities to perform as fighting men
so how does a crazy horse emerge from a
broad cultural blueprint and set himself
apart
perhaps he is testimony to the premise
that some things cannot be taught
perhaps there is something innate that
some have and others don't men and women
who coach young athletes point out that
while skill and methodology can be
taught to any athlete the physical
attributes of speed and quickness are
frequently the difference between a good
athlete and an outstanding one
many people dream of becoming leaders
while others shun the opportunity even
when it falls into their laps general
george patton of world war ii fame
certainly sought the responsibilities of
leadership and reveled in its rewards
and prestige when he was successful
crazy horse on the other hand was not as
quick to grab the opportunity when it
came and literally had no desire to talk
about his exploits but both were
exceptional leaders and their
accomplishments
could not have been achieved without a
certain amount of basic ability as well
as the experience of winning and losing
what is less obvious is that both of
them also had inherent characteristics
only a few of us have those
characteristics enabled them to perform
daring and reckless deeds and make bold
decisions and to inspire others to
follow them
what those characteristics are by name
or label is often difficult to identify
but the consequences they enable are not
difficult to see
you guys had some attributes you know
and i that that question comes up a lot
our leaders born were made and i always
my answer
which i wrote about leadership strategy
and tactics is
you're gonna have some strengths and
some weaknesses all of us are are you
gonna be lucky enough to have you know
the full the full uh catalog of great
leadership assets chances are about
zero are you could you be a george
patton
that you know has you're articulate and
you're smart and you're calm and you're
you have control of your emotions you
can read people like all those things
yeah i guess but it's going to be very
rare
we're going to have strength and
weaknesses and and occasionally some
people are going to get
that level of charisma
and
an influence over other people um
that's going to come from a place maybe
not maybe you can't teach that
there's parts of leadership that you can
absolutely teach there's parts of even
you know the way you carry yourself that
you can improve
but
what we what we always teach people is
you got to build a team of leaders that
help you with the your areas of weakness
so if there's something you're not maybe
not that great at find someone on your
team that is
boying if you want to find
step one to success hey start treating
everybody with respect
and
and and like they said with their
leaders their their their deal is your
job is to teach is to take care of the
people
and then people will do almost anything
for you
um
[Music]
yeah this is one of the lessons that you
just
you you could take away from this and
and see that like
crazy horse is doing all these things
but he's not really bragging about it
but everybody sees it and everyone else
is talking about it which makes it seem
even greater
and then um you know when he comes back
from a raid the first thing he does he's
like i got all these horses let me go
give them to the widows and let me
divide up all this stuff and give it and
take care of
take care of everyone which is a job yep
put others before yourself step one
going back the book black buffalo woman
red cloud's niece was the love of his
life politics however influenced her
choice for a husband she married no
water only because he was of an
influential family and their union
enabled a broader influence on a
stronger political base crazy horse was
of course heartbroken in time the wound
would heal but as is often the case a
true level is never completely forgotten
a few years later when the opportunity
arose black buffalo woman followed her
heart and left her husband lakota women
can make a choice because societal norms
allowed it but in her case a jealous
husband did not and this is him just
kind of debriefing this
crazy horse had put himself in harm's
way many times as a fighting man but he
probably never came as close to dying as
he did when no water showed up with a
borrowed pistol and shot him in the face
it was no waters intention to kill crazy
horse and he thought he did the
subsequent furor brought several
factions on the brink of bloodshed on
one side some wanted to defend no water
and on the other some wanted to avenge
crazy horse to prevent any violence
crazy horse gave up the love of his life
for a second time
those who were jealous of him were quick
to influence the old men leaders to
strip him of the position of shirt
wearer
crazy horse willingly gave up the shirt
but the status he had achieved
circumvented the loss of influence many
people though not totally overlooking
his mistake still regarded him as a
strong leader and remained loyal to him
it was a lesson not lost on him never
again did he put his own desires above
the needs of the people
that was yet another example for others
to follow true leadership is rarely the
consequent consequence of election
appointment dictatorship or inheritance
good leadership overall is much too
critical to be left to elected
politicians monarchs managers
administrators supervisors and directors
having authority does not make anyone a
leader true leadership is exercised when
someone performs a necessary or critical
task and accomplishes an objective
thereby setting an example
most of us will never face the daunting
task of leading men and women into
combat but we will likely have an
opportunity to set an example we may not
carry titles such as president governor
mayor general or even chief but we can
be leaders simply by demonstrating that
effort can be made tasks can be
accomplished
um yeah you know what's interesting you
look at a seal platoon and
there's gonna be
between one and five liters in there
hopefully there might be zero but that's
chances are very small of that
there's gonna be one to five and they
might be any one of the platoon
and you can just see and if they're well
balanced you know like there's some
young guy or
you know one cruise wonder that's just
has good natural leadership ability
smart he's
has his ego in check and he can make
things happen and it doesn't matter that
he's not the chief it doesn't matter
he's not the lieutenant
and as long as the chief and lieutenant
are humble enough hey he's a good leader
hey you want to run this thing it's
going to be fine occasionally those guys
get mad they get scared they get
intimidated
they don't want someone
running things they think they should be
and
yeah i've seen it where
you get like a new guy in a platoon
and he isn't necessarily calling any
shots
but because his demeanor he's like got a
good demeanor he's never bummed out it's
like oh yeah everything's really
terrible and he's like yeah this is
whatever and you'll watch that like his
his influence because he's got a good
attitude even in a worse situation will
bleed over the rest of the platoons like
guys are kicking rocks and saying this
this is dumb
that that that that great attitude
is
is contagious so that leadership kind of
by example even when they're not really
influencing people what to do they're
influencing the overall effectiveness of
the unit by bringing its morale up raise
the morale that's freaking priceless
priceless
the hits just keep on coming
um
crazy horse who now has a different wife
uh he who he has a daughter with she
dies
death was not new to him men died in
battle sometimes and he was not
surprised by that they were gone or at
that or the way that they had died as
fighting men
but the bundle atop his scaffold was
harder reality it was a reality that
challenged the goodness in life
he fell across it and wept
uncontrollably days past
there was thunder some wind and a little
rain when he could no longer stay awake
he slept beneath the scaffold curl
curled up under a robe he ignored hunger
and thirst worm had told him a kind of
coughing sickness unknown before the
whites came had taken her
though he had tried he could find no
medicine to help her finally when no
more tears would come crazy horse took
his leave
the news that awaited him fanned his
anger even more soldiers had gone into
the black hills a large contingent
according to the sketchy reports from
the few from a few lakota who had who
had the misfortune of being in the wrong
place at the wrong time a group friendly
to the whites had been watching the
column of wagons and the soldiers when
they when they were attacked one lakota
was killed and another wounded they
somehow managed to escape to tell their
story
so now you're you know you're blaming
the death of your daughter
on the whites as well
and now they're going into your holy
land
yeah
uh
so now they go out and start
just
basically killing whites where they can
find them the most vulnerable at this
time is the miners people that are out
in these little mining camps and so they
start initiating more of a
more of a guerrilla warfare and this is
something that
you know knowing what we know now about
insurgencies that would have been the
call because they couldn't get people to
unite but that fighting like an
insurgent war would have been the
well would have been another possibility
and that's what he kind of end up doing
here he says the tactics crazy horse and
his companions were simple yet effective
after observing isolated miners camps to
determine their numbers and weapons they
positioned themselves and swept in if
the terrain was
was rough and offered good cover they
sneaked in close on foot before they
attacked in open areas with little cover
they charged in on horses that's kind of
crazy because that's exactly what we
would do like if we had if we could
sneak into a target on foot we'd do that
if we couldn't we just drive the
vehicles right up to the target and
that's what the exact same thing they
would do massive explosive breathing
yeah
we're coming in
in either situation they use their
lances and war clubs and the silent bow
quite effectively rarely did any minor
react quickly enough to fire a gun which
worked in lakota's favor without
gunshots to warn anyone else in the area
the miners in the next valley or
watershed remained oblivious and thus
vulnerable to attack
says this it was necessary to attack the
miners and kill them they were
trespassers and thieves not honorable
enemies the tactics they used were the
only way to fight them especially in the
black hills strike hard and fast inflict
inflict as much chaos and as many
casualties as possible and then withdraw
swiftly
that kind of fighting could play to the
code's strengths and skills as fighters
good at close combat crazy horse spoke
these thoughts to his companions as they
rode home and they listened and agreed
they'd seen firsthand what could be done
if enough lakota fighting men could be
persuaded to fight in the same way and
if enough bullets and powder could be
obtained the whites could be driven away
yeah i mean that's the only strategy
they got right because they the miners
have got all these things they need they
got guns and they got bullets they're
not getting those from any anybody else
and so they just sneak in pick them up
sneak in pick them out
meanwhile red cloud it was learned was
making the trip to persuade the powers
in washington to remove the little agent
from his agency
when all is said and done it didn't
matter who the agent was on spotted tail
agency or on the red cloud agency as
long as there was an agent and the
lakota accepted annuities the whites
were in control
but when red cloud and the others
returned and there were many supposed
head men who made the trip the news they
brought back incensed the wild lakota
and you made this distinction i haven't
pulled it out yet but there's basically
the the ones that are living in the
agencies and then there's the lakota
that are wild that are still living in
the traditional way to the best of their
ability
and i say the best of the ability
because
they relied heavily on buffalo and the
buffalo were being wiped out
and so
this is this makes living in their
traditional way
much more difficult in some cases
probably impossible
the great father wanted to buy the black
hills
sell the heart of everything that is
sell the dust of the ancestors
not looking not there's there's lakota
that we're just we're not doing it
the day now there's
more politics take place and eventually
they're supposed to all come and report
the day when all lakota had to report to
the agencies had come and gone the
northern camps were nervous watching the
horizons for the first sign of soldiers
that they had heard had been gathering
at fort fetterman winter relaxed its
grip and a span of warm days had melted
the snow and fogged the ice on the
creeks and rivers he dog took advantage
the opportunity to head for the agency
his contingent of eight lakota families
were mostly women and children in no
condition to outrun mounted soldiers
before he left crazy horse had ridden up
into the hills unable to watch his
closest friend give in to the agency
though he understood all too painfully
he dogs reasons
the spaces vacated by eight lodges were
not as big as the holes left in the
hearts of the relatives who watched
their loved ones riding away slowly and
uncertainly looking back frequently
uh i mean you know the guy's got a bunch
of women and kids and
he knows he's going to do so much and
sitting bull sent out his carefully
chosen messengers to announce that the
people should gather near chalk buttes
in late spring and treating them to
speak wisely and clearly to the leaders
among the lakota as well as the dakota
and nakota
he wanted his messengers to appeal to
their sense of pride especially to those
who are surely disenchanted with life on
the agencies so sitting bull's another
wild
one of the indians
and he's
very i mean obviously we've all heard of
sitting bull and so he has incredible
amount of influence and he's starting to
try and gather people up and unite them
a little bit
so that starts to take place more and
more people arrived almost every day the
horse herd was growing and eating down
the sparse grass around the buttes some
of the men said perhaps there were as
many as seven thousand heads sitting
bull is already at work inviting the
older leaders to his lodge
he was an impressive and charismatic man
a slight limp from a gunshot wound to
his hip during his days as a young
fighting man served only to give him
more credibility
he had earned nearly 70 battle honors
more than any man
at the gathering except crazy horse
now past the age of 50 he had a solid
reputation as a wise leader and
counselor enhanced by his status as a
medicine man he was immensely pleased at
the at the response to his message and
announced he would conduct a sundance
spiritually as well as psychologically
it was the right thing at the right time
it could only serve to unify the people
and add to the feelings of strength and
pride that seemed to be growing as
quickly as the horse heard it was that
kind of insight that made him an
influential leader
the encampment moved west across the
powder
and the tongue into the valley of the
rosebud
and across it as well turning at the
northern slopes of the wolf mountains
into the broken country
near the greasy grass river
while sitting bull is hard at work for
the hearts and minds of the people crazy
hearse crazy horse sent scouts in all
directions feeling among the military
leaders was that the biggest threat laid
to lay
to the south from three stars army
and
um
the this book does not have a ton of
detail about the battle at rosebud or
really the battle at little bighorn
those are detailed pretty well in the
book i fought with custer and also in
the book wooden leg
but there is sort of a debriefing here
on on some of the things that when that
went down
going to the book the rose bug bud fight
as the battle came to be known was the
toughest combat crazy horse had seen
the battle of hundred and hand ten years
earlier that was when they
surrounded those soldiers and killed
them out yeah
the battle of the hundred in the hand
ten years earlier had had its own set of
circumstances that made it tough but at
the rosebud lakota the lakota faced a
larger and more heavily armed enemy
force three star soldiers were both
infantry and cavalry forcing lakota to
adjust to different tactics as the
fighting progressed attack was met with
counter-attack as the day wore on the
valley of the rosebud thundered with
gunfire and dust hung in the air late in
the afternoon it was evident that the
soldiers were disorganized fighting in
scattered units their effectiveness
significantly reduced crazy horse was
notified even though nearly
a hundred had arrived at mid-morning the
lakota and sahelia were critically low
on ammunition
sensing that three stars wouldn't be
able to mount any pursuit crazy horse
sent the word to withdraw crazy horse
rode with he-dog bid big road and good
weasel
among others as they once again chased
dusk into night there was no pursuit
from the soldiers to speak of
the feverish aftermath of combat slowly
faded as the reality of the day began to
take hold 10 good men and been killed
and many wounded in a day or two the the
scouts crazy horse had left behind would
report on the
soldiers so that's the first big battle
that they engage is is that battle at
rosebud
and then six days had passed since the
rosebud fight victory dances still went
far into the night and the fighting men
were asked to tell the stories of their
involvement the mood of the encampment
had changed from initial uncertainty to
one of comfortable sense of strength
hardly anyone no matter how old could
remember the lakota ever see gathering
in such numbers for any purpose
at midday sitting bull sent criers to
announce the move
to the greasy grass valley and by mid
afternoon the first lodges were taken
down and the families began moving by
sundown most of the encampment was gone
except for a few lodges and the sundance
arbor
fast forward up a little bit more
they're
in their kind of camp now
and we'll go to the book the sides of
the council lodge and then rolled up to
allow cross ventilation a few men were
waiting in anticipation meeting with
sitting bull
women had already brought food sitting
bull had been busy through most of the
night attending to a gravely ill woman
he arrived at the council lodge just as
a slight din of commotion came from the
south end of the encampment where he had
just been
a lone lakota rider splashed across the
greasy grass filled bank to bank with
the heavy spring runoff from the
mountain snows
gaining the west bank he began to shout
prepare yourselves the soldiers are
coming the soldiers are coming
and this is when we get into the
little bighorn battle
the soldiers had crossed the river far
to the south near the mouth of ash creek
and tried to gallop
tried galloping their horses across the
long open flood plain toward the south
south end of the encampment they had
been quickly driven back and then chased
across the river many were killed at the
water crossing after heavy fighting in
some trees near the river as far as
crazy horse and the other leaders were
concerned that was the first fight
gaul of the hunk papa and ol and oglala
battle leaders black moon and big road
were among those who had courageously
led 200 fighting men in that action
the second fight started at medicine
tale coulee
more soldiers had tried to cross into
the encampment from the north end but
were stopped by a small determined group
of boys and old men
armed mostly with old single shot rifles
by then many of the women children old
people were fleeing to the northwest
somehow worded reached crazy horse and
gall of the second attempted incursion
gaul immediately disengaged from the
first fight and led a hundred men to
medicine tail and crossed
the soldiers galloped away up a long
slope to the north crazy horse had
hurried to to his lodge and found
blackshaw that's his wife waiting with
his second war horse the camp was in
total confusion not only were women and
children running away to safety men were
galloping through to hurry to the second
fight shouts and screams filled the air
gunshots could be heard to the south and
now thinly to the north
he took his second war horse and
gathered as many men as
to him as he could
if a second group of soldiers was
heading north north they could be
circling to attack from another
direction it made sense to try and flank
them so he led the men who were with him
to an old crossing guessing the soldiers
would stay on the high ground he had
crossed the river and raced to meet them
if they came off the end of the high
north south ridge where he knew they lay
to the east
on the slopes across the river they
circled to the east and encountered 20
or so soldiers
whom they chased back to the main body
the gunfire never stopped
he heard it as they crossed the river a
continuous sound rather like someone
tearing canvas
gaul and his men crazy horse heard later
stayed in pursuit of the running
soldiers even though they did not gain a
ridge
at first the soldiers were organized
even managing to dismount and form
skirmish lines to fire at the oncoming
lakota but gaul's relentless pursuit
broke their lines and after that they
were running away and their fire was no
longer effective
crazy horse led a charge when the
soldiers tried to push north off their
ridge
by then gunfire was thinning it was
sporadic and then there was silence
the second fight was over as he rode
through the dust
and he could see how it unfolded
dead horses and dead soldiers were
strewn along the path they had taken
what's what's different about little
bighorn battlefield than gettysburg is
because the scale of it's much smaller
they actually they have markers for
where these soldiers were dying and they
went back and they could find all the
skirmish lines and everything so you can
see it in real you know laid out where
bodies fell
um
they came up from the river and then
across and then just the disaster that
happened i mean you can all the way it's
laid out and the bodies are laid out you
can see that the guys are just the last
couple guys are just trying to get away
and
getting mauled
meanwhile the guys down at the other
position
they're surrounded up on that hill
they're waiting for their turn they're
wondering where because custard
splits forces all these times and
they're wondering where did he go did he
leave us
and some guys kind of push out and they
can see
this big swirling
thing and they can see the lakota
shooting down the ground they're like oh
he's done
and then
they wind up getting there under siege
yeah
yeah looking forward to uh walking that
battlefield myself um
going back to the story here after that
the the you know sitting bulls trying to
keep
people there
but
they they kind of start to like it's the
fighting's over and kind of people got
stuff to do right well there's another
element coming toward them too and
they're like hey we gotta move everybody
yeah yeah and i'm even going past that
so that happens um
and eventually he says this what was
left of the largest gathering ever of
lakota separated into several
encampments moving along the eastern
foothills of the shining mountain soon
after the departure from greasy grass
small groups began breaking away to head
for the agencies
sitting bull like crazy horse was deeply
disappointed because they were losing
the strength of numbers
despite the best efforts of sitting bull
the people scattered some made excuses
saying it was time to hunt and make meat
for the coming winter which was more
difficult now because of the scarcity of
buffalo others unabashedly headed for
the agencies sitting bull finally headed
north to more familiar territory crazy
horse took his people east to the black
hills finding a sheltered valley
northwest of the mountains to hide
the camps
from there he led raids into the black
hills
there
that continues for a while
um and this is all
he does a great job in the book of just
this kind of torment and anguish
that
that crazy horse is going through as as
he sees what's happening
um at some point dull knife another one
of his friends informed crazy horse that
he was forced to consider living giving
in to life on the agency if it meant his
people would be safe from facing
continual conflict with the long knives
the idea was debated long and frequently
strangely and opportunity presented
itself when messengers arrived bringing
word to from three stars who had been
given assurance that the wild lakota
would be allowed to select the location
for their own agencies if they signed a
peace agreement
the only drawback was that it included
an agreement to sell to the sale of the
black hills
in spite of deep seated suspicions crazy
horse agreed that this important issue
should be discussed face to face with
the long knives
crazy horse and a long large detachment
of warriors escorted the delegation
north to the fort on the elk river
a group of crow scouts met the emma
series just outside the walls of the
fort making friendly gestures to
indicate their peacefulness as the eight
lakota rode past them toward the gate
weapons were drawn
suddenly and the crow opened fire at
point-blank range on the unarmed lakota
and then fled on horseback crazy horse
charged down from the bluff but stopped
when mounted soldiers emer emerged from
the fort instinctively the lakota
emissaries turned their horses and
galloped for the safety of the bluffs
and protection of the escort warriors
only three rejoined the warriors five
laid dead on the ground near the gates
of the fort
so the
chance for peace and the crow this gets
gets like completely fumbled
fumbled
and um
yeah you know and the crow had
motivations to do what they did yeah um
and can you know that
i think the guys come out of the
thing there and try and hunt them down
because they realize oh dang it
yep
this is
um
fast forward a little bit more the harsh
winter should have been in a turn at
least providing a brief respite from
worrying about the long knives but that
was not to be to agency lakota carrying
a bold message from bear coat found the
crazy horse camp if the wild lakota
moved into the agencies they would be
given food but would have to give up
their weapons and horses
sword graciously has ever assured crazy
horse's people that it was his idea to
intervene because he didn't want his
friends and relatives dying when peace
and a good life could be had so easily
if crazy horse would come in
meaning surrender his people would be
given food clothing and blankets and
then he would be allowed to return to
powder river area to claim it as his
agency
so like oh
you want we'll give you peace we'll give
you food you can have your own area
only he and sitting bull were stubborn
or perhaps foolish how could anyone
continue resisting when even a brief
battle used up the bullets that took
several days of scrounging
half the people who followed him wanted
to go into the agency they were tired of
running from the soldiers tired of being
hungry tired of seeing relatives die
they stayed because they believed he had
an answer of some kind
something
that would solve the problem of the
soldiers
yeah
you can
it's just closing in
and there's really
not much of an option yeah these
essentially you're glaciers glacier yeah
forces
just towards him and he's going to get
crushed and squeezed in one direction
so they end up
going to camp robinson
um
fast forward a little bit here nearly
four months had passed since crazy horse
people had arrived at camp robinson 900
and all with over 1500 horses the
soldiers had taken their horses first
and then their guns and then their hope
in four months the promise of an agency
of their own in the north that turned
into an impossible dream he blamed
himself partly because he could do
nothing
perhaps if he had learned to be an
agency lakota and put on the defeated
smile in the presence of three stars and
other soldier leaders none of this would
be happening
but the soldiers were not the only ones
to cause the turmoil of the past four
months the finger of blame could be
pointed at many lakota as well in fact
they were mostly to blame
the white agents and the army officers
fanned the flames of jealousy and let
little minds that could not think beyond
the moment and little men who yearned
for recognition and power do the rest
there was no other way to look at it
in the end the lakota defeated
themselves
they had the whites outnumbered and
outmanned and did nothing
the entire garrison could have been
overrun by the by enough determined
lakota fighting men with a good plan if
they truly wanted to return to living
the old way in control of their lands
and their lives
instead men stepped over each other to
betray their own relatives in order to
obtain the power handed out by the
whites a power they couldn't get on
their own
and he details some of this just ego
drama that's going on and they have the
opportunity you know if i'm
if i'm in camp and you know jason crazy
horse jason's out there still being a
wild lakota and i want more power in the
camp maybe i say hey you know you don't
want to you don't want to deal with that
jason crazy he's too crazy out there
you don't want to put him in a power
position you don't want to get like all
these things this happens a buffalo hunt
had been promised
but there had been no hunt and crazy
horse understood why first someone with
more power than three stars had to say
that the lakota could go chasing buffalo
if given the opportunity three stars
reasoned
the hunters would keep going perhaps all
the way to grandmother's land to join
sitting bull which is canada by the way
adding to that
some among the lakota complained to
three stars that if crazy horse and his
young men were allowed to hunt buffalo
then everyone must be allowed
and it was a lakota who warned that it
was dangerous to put guns in the hands
of crazy horse so he's just getting
stabbed in the back by
you know as his dream pointed out
by some of his own people
after many of the soldier leaders at
camp robinson came to crazy horse with
horse with questions about the greasy
grass fight and the defeat of the long
hair which is custer
two agency chiefs sent messages
complaining to three star
perhaps there was no place for another
agency chief crazy horse thought to
reassure his uncle red cloud
that he had no wish to be made a chief
of any kind
but he knew anything he had to say to
them would not be regarded as truth
but eventually the rumors did fly it was
said three star would make crazy horse
chief over everyone including spotted
tail and red clouds you can see this is
just like political drama to make
matters worse many of the lesser soldier
leaders were themselves saying that
crazy horse could influence the younger
men better than the two older leaders
could
through it all he had tried to talk to
three stars about the promise of a
northern agency day after day traveling
to robinson from cottonwood creek
if you want your agency some of crazy
horse's friends said carefully in low
voices for it was hard to know who might
be listening you will have to travel to
their place of power where the great
father lives and speak to him face to
face of course they weren't warned if
three star sends you a head of red cloud
or spotted tail they will find a way to
make it difficult for us while you're
gone they will find a way to take you
down when you return
crazy horse had no wish to travel to the
great father and curry favor from a man
he didn't know
he would be out of place and only
something for show someone to perform
for the powerful crazy horse did not
wish to be a thing of curiosity
fast forward a little bit more and now
he's trying to make a deal man he's
trying to like
get it done he knows what what where
these things are going
he's late in the game
but he's trying to make it happen
um
yeah i mean he's got it he's got to
think about the women and the children
at this point and he's like well you
know
i could keep fighting but then who's
going to protect them and that that's
where
this is where the guy's just so
honorable because he just he knows what
his responsibility is
it's not like how many soldiers i can
kill because he can kill quite a few
more
um
and he can probably you know inspire a
bunch of the young men on the thing to
to to um rise up but to what end
and at the end of the day it's the women
and children that are going to suffer so
then he's like i gotta
try and fix this and negotiate the best
deal that he can at that point
so he starts to put a deal together
lieutenant lee the soldier leader in
charge at spotted tales agency sent word
that crazy horse must come to the
soldier house crazy horse rode out with
touch the clouds and white thunder
spotted tail and over a hundred of his
young men met them on the trail lee
arrived with black crow and louis
bordeaux and was frightened seeing that
he was between the mini kanju and
aglala on one side and spotted tails on
the other there were shouts and threats
hurled back and forth and weapons
brandished until crazy horse raised a
hand and silenced slowly fell over the
gathering lee now very frightened told
crazy horse that he must return to
robinson and make it good with the
soldier leaders there
so the night passed the morning came
when the sun arose he hurried to the
soldier house to speak to lieutenant lee
to assure him that he had not changed
his mind he was ready to speak with
randall he was one of the leaders to
make things good so with touch the
clouds swift bear and black crow along
they started out for camp robinson
the first group of blue coated lakota
men
met them along the trail they said
nothing informed a wide half circle
around crazy horse and the others
further on more blue coated lakota
arrived and now they became a mob of
more than 60. it was then that crazy
horse knew he was in trouble so now you
have lakotas
that are wearing the the military the
american military jacket
fast thunder was lost in the crowd so
too or he dog and touched the clouds
all around was noise of running and
scuffling as if men were pushing
together crazy horse was pushed toward a
square house made of logs a strange
place for randall to be before he could
help himself he was through the open
doorway
there was a bad smell a man with dark
hair and braids rose from the corner
then he saw the iron bars
he spun on a heel and saw a man little
big man blocking the opening
crazy horse shoved the shorter man aside
and tried to push past but almost
immediately felt little big man grabbed
both of his arms from behind
with a great effort he pulled himself
free and reached into the opening of his
blanket for the
knife
there were shouts of both soldiers and
the lakota let me go he said to little
big man let me go
the man
the oglala warrior who had ridden into
battle with him stood fast perhaps it
was the blue coat of the soldier that
had turned his heart
with a sudden swipe crazy horse slashed
the arm of the coat and immediately
blood flowed and little big man jumped
back
with a step crazy horse was outside and
there was movement everywhere more hands
grabbed at him from either side brown
hands holding him fast the strident
voice of a soldier yelled from the
middle of the confusion came a soldier
thrusting with the knife at the end of
his rifle
those near him heard crazy horse gasp
and saw his knees begin to wobble
brown hands still holding his arms even
as the soldier withdrew the long knife
let me go
they heard him say quietly
you've gotten me hurt
then he fell
and
crazy horse
died
a few hours later
um it details that in the book
and
yeah and his dream
the dream that he had became fulfilled
and
yeah again it it
it makes me think about that
that
quote that native american quote from
that podcast with with micah fink um
that the diagnosis is a curse
and this seems to be something similar
when
you know that thing when we're driving
go through that driving course and they
warn you when you're going through like
a tactical driving course and you're
driving around the track or you're
driving in and out of traffic you're
doing these things and they warn you
they give you a warning they say when
you're driving if you look at something
you need what you need to look at is the
opening you need to look at the part of
the track that you can drive you need to
look at the part of this this the road
that you can go through that you can
make it through because if you look at
another car or you look at a guard rail
or you look at a ditch that's where
you're going that's where you're going
to end up we
go where we aim
and i don't know this is a
self-fulfilling prophecy here
but
it might be and i i think it's a good
idea to try and set yourself so your
sights
on a positive outcome
another thought i had about this is
you know bh liddell hart
who
go listen to some podcasts that i've
done on ph level heart
the indirect approach but
he also talked about the fact that
what happens to profits you have profits
and you have leaders what happens to
profits profits die
when you go out you profit you you make
statements and you don't compromise you
die
and your
your message will get traction later on
and and it's usually the leaders that
take the message from the prophet and
turn it into something that can be
brought to fruition
you know they they use compromise they
use understanding and they use
relationships to to move an idea forward
in a more practicable way
but the
the believers
that don't compromise
oftentimes
they're crucified they're killed
and um
pretty clear
where crazy horse fell in that
category which category he fell into
powerful lessons to be learned
if you want to join us on the
battlefield
little bighorn we're going to be up
there in august
august 16th and 17th and and then august
18th and 19th we're doing back to back
we'll go out there you'll learn we'll
learn we'll explore so many characters
custer is a leadership lesson after
leadership lesson about what not to do
um
so much so much incredible stuff so
um you want to join us up there
we'll see you go to echelonfront.com
check out events and you can find it
we're also going to gettysburg
past couple podcasts we're about
gettysburg we're doing that
may
11th and 12th and then again on may 13th
and 14th then there's a dinner before
both those the night before so if you
want to come those check them out
if and look
go anyways you don't have to go with us
go
and and learn
this
as americans
all of this is part of our shared
history
all these lessons in both these
battlefields there's so much for us to
to learn from and we can learn from you
know in the case of a lot of things that
we heard the soldiers were doing were
not
good like hey this is what i'm not gonna
do this is not an honorable way to
behave
and then we can see
when the lakota are talking about
generosity being
the
a virtue of a warrior and then
considering that and saying that is a
virtue that i want to strive to
as an american
um
yeah and that
this is such a great way to learn these
lessons
it is
um
thanks for listening if you want to
support yourself while you're supporting
us you go to jockofield.com get some
get some medicine
is am i allowed to say that yes probably
i don't know in the context that we've
got right you get some medicine you get
some more good medicine for you yes it
is um
get some stuff for your joints
get some stuff for your immunity
get some stuff for
your
energy levels sure energy
we got an energy drink
yep that
is not a typical energy drink it's good
for you yep it's good for so
and
it does seem kind of like a rough
transition a little bit it's totally
wrong
[Music]
like a lot of these these like native
american stories or whatever for
whatever reason i
i don't know we were talking
earlier where
i kind of get a little bit more into
them i don't know why maybe because a
lot of times it starts with
in just right at the beginning how they
start with how they're raised like how
the kids are raised and then you know i
have young kids so i'm like man i want
my kids like crazy horse what was his
name before crazy horse
light hair light hair
yeah so so just from the beginning
you're into it you know and then you
kind of you know you kind of cheering
for him and rooting for him then at the
end it's all tragic and then now i got
to tell everybody how the jocko
discipline goes so healthy for you it's
hard dope it is it is hard transition
well
we if you want to support
that's a good way to do it origin
originusa.com we're making a bunch of
stuff in america jacquelinestore.com we
got some t-shirts for you
uh some others some other stuff
um
we've got jocko underground.com in case
we get shut down for whatever reason you
can go there and help us out we got a
youtube channel so that's cool
a bunch of books echelon front or our
leadership consultant you can check that
we got an online training platform
which is
which is awesome these these leadership
lessons that we're talking about they're
not they're skills that you can learn
look is there some charismatic thing
that crazy horse had that maybe we can't
give you yes
but there's an
unbelievable
number of ways that you can improve your
leadership
and that's what we what's we teach in
the academy you know at the academy
when we do our live sessions right every
single one of them now someone gives a
sit rep yeah we're like hey i've been
i've been practicing this stuff i've
been checking my ego i've been working
with the other teams on our group and
here's all these massive successes
and they just compile every week so you
can hear
from other leaders that are putting
effort into leadership instead of just
not really paying attention to it and
then then you can quantify their
successes
yeah so cool also to you mentioned like
leaders say other leaders whatever i
think a lot of times we talk about this
from time to time where some peop some a
lot of people i think don't hear the
word leader and then it's like that's me
which kind of they were taught were you
they're straight up talking about that
where it's like hey you don't got to be
the general you don't got to be the
manager you don't you know everyone's
kind of like a leader for for different
reasons than the title you know great
point man and so
when you kind of
and you know hang around this group a
lot you know i'm not leading no i'm not
i'm no manager you know nothing like
that but
you got yourself a little team now i do
reaping massive you know rewards from
you guys and it's just me you know from
the beginning so i think that's like a
good thing to bring up um and a good
distinction where it's like yeah sure
you're talking to quote unquote leaders
but it's not just the boss you know it's
like everybody's on there no there's a
and there's individuals whether they're
maybe they're running their own business
or they're just working somewhere yeah
and they're they're leading themselves
and they're part of the mission yeah
and you get we get great feedback from
them too yeah man you know and here's
another thing this translates everywhere
so
in the last couple i've been in people
have talked about
parenting issues
the leadership straight up right yeah
it's the lifetime leadership and they're
like hey i had you know i had this issue
and i've been having this issue with my
son and then i realized
wait a minute it's not my son it's
something that i'm doing wrong and i've
adjusted the way that i interact with
them and now
things are great you know and they're
looking at themselves first and taking
ownership and if that what you just said
hits you if you're listening this right
now you just heard jason just say that
like oh it's
something wrong with me as a parent and
you go oh that's
i'm that's my kid you better do what i
tell if that's what your attitude is i'm
telling you got a rude awakening coming
your way
it is leadership it's the same you want
to impose stuff on your children it's
not going to go well for you it's not
so be careful that thing you just said
or said about the
the example or whatever where it's like
oh yeah i i used like this lesson i
looked at myself for whatever yeah any
time where i
looked at it as no it's not them not
doing the right thing it's me not doing
the right thing every single time
hundred percent 100 not the time 99 to
make that one time you know kind of what
no 100 of the time it worked
when and when i have a discipline issue
with my kids and then i do run the
internal debrief or iris gives me the
debris
then it gets fixed and it's like well
this is what i did wrong and this is
what i need to do better next time i do
those things next time and then there
ain't an issue yeah just like
so that's the that's extreme ownership
extremeownership.com if you want to come
and join us and a bunch of other people
on that we're doing it all the time if
if you want to help out some service
members go to america's
mightywarriors.org where mark lee's mom
set up an incredible organization and
and also check out heroes and horses
heroes and horses.com
uh micah fink
we're talking sweat lodge there's some
ancient rituals we're talking about
rituals being brought back that's one
that that he's doing that to help out a
bunch of veterans that need it so
look at that as well if you can help out
if you need more of us we're on social
media
watch out for the algorithm warning yeah
jason's jason and gardner
jason.gardner
on instagram and jason and gardner on
twitter
and
echo's adequate charles on everything
i'm at jocko willing and thanks to all
of our military personnel out there
especially today the native americans
the native americans from our military
that have served in every conflict
america has been involved in starting
with the revolutionary war
and in the civil war in the civil war in
the civil war where general eli parker
member of the seneca tribe
he was the military secretary to ulysses
s grant
he was there when general lee
surrendered and general lee
looked at eli parker a native american
and said i'm glad to see one real
american here to which parker replied
we are all americans
that's a righteous attitude
and the native americans continued to
serve the code talkers in world war ii
ira hayes
[Music]
raising the flag on iwo jima he was from
the pima people
10 000 native americans fought in korea
42 000 fought in vietnam
19 percent of native americans have
served since 9 11.
including one named michael kenneth bell
who was a member of the fort peck tribes
in a seal who i worked with briefly in
2005 was a complete warrior
and who was murdered in 2006 when he was
home on leave
but a salute to him and all the native
american warriors that serve our country
and thanks also to our police and law
enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
thank you for your service here at home
and everyone else
[Music]
there is another account
there's another account of crazy horse's
death
from a man named charles a eastman who
was a member of the santee dakota tribe
and he was the first native american to
be certified in western medicine he
wrote a book called indian heroes and
great chiefs
and in that book
he reported
that crazy horse and that book was
written maybe
1915 1920. in that book he reported that
crazy horse after he was stabbed with
the bayonet
he didn't say let me go you've hurt me
what
he said was let me go
let me die fighting
and i don't know
which one of those is more historically
accurate but that sounds like a good
plan let me die fighting
until next time
this is jason and echo and jocko
out